What is up friends? As always, welcome
to
another live stream.
Especially a warm welcome to all of our
new subscribers. You may have ended up
here from Facebook, Instagram,
Google, I guess, who knows where. But if
you're new, welcome. Thanks for being
here. Tonight
we're going to be responding to and I
guess you could say reviewing, if you
will,
SDA Church President Ted Wilson's State
of the Unionesque
annual council address from earlier this
week, wherein he refers to this platform
and others as weird people online.
Weird people online. Interesting. Uh,
I'm going to let that that baste for a
little bit. Um, and he claims that the
SDA church is not worried at all, but as
we will see,
this is damage control. Ted has been on
the circuit. If you remember from
uh it's been a few months now. We played
a clip. Ted was so kind to provide the
uh the introduction of the funeral
stream for Ellen White, which was from
Doug Bachelor's uh hold the line
conference, which was really the damage
control conference. So Ted has been on
the circuit with this for quite some
time now. And so I think you're going to
see tonight that um while he may say
that they're not worried, uh I think
they're a little bit worried. Um this
platform, folks, is making a difference.
It's growing and we don't have any plans
of slowing down. If anything,
we're just getting started.
Our one-year anniversary is in a couple
of weeks and we have a lot of stuff
planned for the future. So they can say
what they want,
but when the numbers continue to be
impacted by this platform
because more people are being reached
all over the world with the true Christ
and his gospel, it won't matter what
sort of messaging is said from the
stage. We want as many SDAs as possible
to come to know the true Christ and his
gospel. That's our mission. We are
equipping Christians, raising the
general awareness of the body of Christ
to reach Adventists with the truth.
That's the mission. It's not dunking on
the SDA church.
It's not exposing Adventism like
Adventists like to often say.
And based on the data
as well as the testimonies that continue
to pour in, it's working. It's working.
So, if you are an Adventist leader, Ted,
if you watch this,
I'll take being a weird person on the
internet in exchange for the gospel
being advanced and Christ's kingdom
growing any day.
You guys are going to have to do a lot
better than that and start dealing with
the substance,
which includes, by the way, as you're
going to see tonight, not assuming that
all former Adventists are the same or
have the same arguments.
Now, before we dive in, I want to remind
you guys, been doing this pretty
regularly,
please visit answeringadaptism.com.
You can donate, partner with us, access
a huge library of resources, sign up for
our newsletter, all that good stuff.
Please use it before sending us
questions, folks. I say this regularly
just because we get so many questions.
It is hard to answer them all.
We're a small team. We don't have time
to answer every single question, but a
lot of them that come in, they're
already on the website. So, please use
this website. It is our gift to you.
This search bar up top is a very handy
tool. You can type in a name. You can
type in a specific question. Now, if you
get super specific with the question,
it's only going to populate as specific
as you get. So, you may get too specific
to where it whittleles down. But folks,
you can type in topics, you can type in
categories, you can type in I mean mark
of the beast.
Voila. Anything on the site that
discusses anything pertaining to the
mark of the beast is going to populate.
It's going to populate up to 10 uh
options for you. But just click the
little search or the little magnifying
glass. It'll take you to an archive page
where it will cover everything on the
site that deals with such topic. So
please, please, please utilize this
site. Again, it is our gift to you and
it is a powerful tool and it will answer
most of the questions that we get coming
in before uh you need to send that sort
of question in. Now, if you don't see
your question on here, feel free to send
it in and we are updating or rather I am
updating I guess um that library
constantly. So, with that said, let's
quickly get into this because it's going
to be another one of those long nights.
Here we go. Good morning, brothers and
sisters.
What a wonderful privilege to see so
many of you here together
at this 2023
annual council where we are focused on
mission. The 7th Day Adventist Church
has been uniquely chosen for mission by
God himself.
The world,
the societies around us, the cultures in
this
world are disintegrating at a rapid
pace.
We've just heard of the tragic
developments in the country of Israel
with Hamas.
Thank you, Robert, for praying for that
and for many other situations.
At our upcoming general conference
session in 2025, our theme is Jesus is
coming. I will go.
Because of Christ's saving power and his
soon return, let's say, Lord, thank you
for choosing me for your mission to the
world. Yes, I will go.
This message today
is not an easy one to present to you.
I ask for your patience, your
indulgence,
and
your loving kindness
because we will address
various issues that have to do with the
sanctity and authenticity
and foundational understanding of this
word.
It is the word of God.
The two songs, the two hymns we're going
to be singing, we sang one already,
have been specially chosen.
Oh, brother and sister.
Be faithful.
Soon Jesus will come for whom we have
waited so long.
Oh, soon we shall enter our glorious
home and join in the conqueror's song.
Oh brother
and sister, be faithful. For why should
we prove unfaithful
to him who hath shown
such deep, such unbounded
and infinite love, who died to redeem us
his own.
Oh brother,
oh sister,
be
faithful.
O,
did you catch that?
Uncle Ted is irked.
He's irked. Do you see that face at the
end? That was the stern parental figure
coming through. Reminds me of Uncle
Frank from Home Alone when he tells
Kevin, "Look what you did, you little
jerk." Has that same vibe. Do you see
his face?
This sets the stage for his entire theme
and scolding that's about to come. Pay
attention to the audience's demeanor
throughout this talk. They look pretty
chill and attentive at this stage, but
pay attention as it goes along because
it periodically pans out to the
audience. It serves as an unspoken
evidence of the browbeating that
permeates Adventism, which can be traced
all the way back to the pioneers in
Ellen White's writings. But his central
theme is that the SDA church is
supposedly uniquely chosen by God with a
unique mission in the world, distinct
and separate from Christians,
and they are to remain faithful to the
old paths understanding of Adventism.
That's the current tug for those that
are unfamiliar with all this right now
that's happening within Adventism. It's
only a matter of time, folks, before
there's a split in this movement.
But as you're going to see, this talk is
basically a scolding of the liberal wing
of the movement that's trying to
repackage Adventism as a big tent
movement with all sorts of um diversity
of thought and ideas, which really makes
Adventism a malaise of understanding
around what it is to actually be an
Adventist, which is why people like
Lauren Seabolde over at the
Adventisttoday.org
and other liberal SDA figures had
meltdowns after this and felt attacked.
But nevertheless, that's where this is
going. So, buckle up.
Seventh day Adventists have been
uniquely chosen for a mission to
proclaim the three angels messages of
Revelation 14 6-12 and the fourth angel
of Revelation 18:es 1-4 with Holy Spirit
power. We are God's remnant church
outlined in Revelation 12:17.
And the dragon was wroth with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed, which keep the commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ. You see, we are joined with God
in this last proclamation to the world.
Revelation 17:14 indicates those who are
with him are called chosen and faithful.
Oh brother, oh sister, be faithful, for
you are called and chosen. 1 Peter
chapter 2 verse 9 explains, "You are a
chosen generation, a royal priesthood, a
holy nation, his own special people,
that you may proclaim the praises of him
who called you out of darkness into his
marvelous light." Now, God tells us in
numerous places in this word about being
chosen. Let's let's look at a few of
them. John 15:16.
You did not choose me, but I chose you
and appointed you that you should go and
bear fruit. Isaiah 43:10. You are my
witnesses, says the Lord, my servant
whom I have chosen. Romans 8:28.
We know that all things work together
for good to those who love God and to
those who are called according to his
purpose. John 6:44,
"No one can come to me unless the Father
who sent me draws him." 1 Thessalonians
1 2 and four. We give thanks to God
always for you all, making mention of
you in our prayers, knowing, beloved
brethren, your election,
you've been chosen by God.
What an enormous privilege to be called
and chosen by God to deliver the last
warning to a perishing world.
And as we were reminded this morning
again, everything is perishing.
Ted, you just got done holding your
Bible up, saying this talk is going to
be about the sanctity, authenticity, and
foundation of the word of God. Sir, the
scriptures nowhere claim that you guys
are chosen by God to proclaim a special
present truth end times message to take
to the rest of the world that only you
have and no one else. You are crossing
wires again, sir. You have a habit of
doing this. We looked at this a few
weeks ago.
You are confusing Ellen White's writings
with scripture
and showing us how ingrained her
writings are within Adventist thought
such that the line between the two is so
blurred that it doesn't even really
exist.
Folks, nowhere does the Bible state that
the Adventist church is the last day
remnant.
This is the great controversy theme
filtering scripture.
I say this a lot. I get Adventists that
want to give flack and say, "Oh, so you
think it has no application to No,
you're going to see here in a in a bit
he's going to get into the only approved
hermeneutic within the SDA church." They
don't even utilize it. He didn't utilize
the her only approved hermeneutic in the
SDA church right there. He just
hopscotched through the Bible and
inserted the SDA church into any place
where the word chosen's using.
Revelation had application to people
before you guys even existed. Sir,
it's had application in every generation
since it was pinned.
You guys were not the original audience
who it also had application to.
This is your great controversy worldview
lens filtering everything for you
leading to such a conclusion. simply
citing Revelation 12:17 when you guys
engage in word association fallacy to
say the Ten Commandments are what's in
view and then relying on the King
James's rendering of faith of Jesus
versus faith in Jesus does not therefore
mean you are who is in focus in the text
again this is great controversy theme
clouding your reading Adventists love to
just assert this as de facto truth when
no this had application to people before
your movement was even born less than
two centuries ago.
Revelation was not a closed book until
you guys came onto the scene like I've
heard so many SDA say my whole life.
But even if Revelation 12:17 folks were
saying what the SDA church asserts,
Ted, your movement is not keeping the
Ten Commandments.
You guys proitize a false god, an idol,
violating the first commandment. You
violate the second commandment more than
anyone else I've ever seen.
Making images of a person of the
Godhead.
You guys uplift a woman who bore the
name of God falsely repeatedly and claim
one has to submit to her writings where
she does such as a part of joining this
supposed remnant.
And it's necessary for salvation after
one has heard this call to do so.
Supposedly,
you guys don't even keep the Sabbath
because you don't understand the new
creation, which we're going to talk
about later.
You don't rest in the person and work of
Christ, which is the gospel rest of the
soul. Nor do you observe the practice
that Jesus himself instituted
postresurrection with his disciples of
the first day rest.
You guys love to tout that Jesus
observed the seventh day Sabbath but
then completely ignore that he changed
that habit postresurrection
which scripture documents for us and
history aligns with by likes of people
like Ignatius disciple of John the
Apostle whose testimony actually aligns
with the scriptures not some grand
conspiracy
and for good reason
because as Ignatius rightly recognized
It has to do with new creation, sir. So,
no, you don't even keep the fourth
commandment by following Jesus's example
that he started with the apostles who
then continued that practice that he
started with them. You observe the the
memorial of the old creation, which was
a type and shadow, not the new creation
memorial.
We're going to talk about this in depth
later, folks. But God in creation did a
mighty work, completed that work, and
then rested from that work the seventh
day.
God in Christ did a mighty work of
redeeming that old creation that fell
into sin, accomplished that work, but
entered his rest not the seventh day,
but the first day,
which is when the work was accomplished.
This is why the new creation has a new
memorial day. The day Jesus entered his
rest for his people.
That's the Christian Sabbath, not the
Jewish old creation Sabbath that you
guys idolize. Again, violating the first
commandment.
If you didn't hopcotch exesus through
the Bible, but walked walked through
text, a walk through the text verse by
verse,
you would see that Hebrews 3 through 4
1-1 is telling you Jesus is a better
Moses, a better Joshua that led a better
Exodus, a better redemption, a better
Sabbath, and brought about a better
creation.
You guys are stuck in a type and shadow
looking for the substance in the shadow.
We're going to get into this verse by
verse later. So, if you're an Adventist,
hold on. I'm sure your head is exploding
right now.
But in order to keep the Sabbath Ted,
you have to be resting in Christ in the
true gospel. You guys don't have the
true gospel.
You have to be gathering with his one
body on the day that he instituted with
the apostles after the resurrection. You
guys don't do this. You abhore it and
actually attribute it to the devil.
But further, your hospital networks
violate the sixth commandment weekly
where they're one of the largest murder
mills of unborn children in California
and you guys make money off of it.
Christians don't sanction such behavior,
let alone perform and profit off of it.
It's like it's in the dedicay. It's like
one of the earliest I mean you got
second century, first century Christians
saying abortions
are not permissible as Christian
behavior.
And you have apologists and pastors in
your own organization that also violate
this command by telling people like me
that they want to see me specifically,
not just my ideology, not just my
theology. They want to see me as a
person destroyed,
which is hatred in the heart. Jesus
calls that murder. Sir,
we may we might hate false doctrine on
on this platform, the false doctrine of
your movement, but not the people. We
don't want to see you guys destroyed.
That's why we're doing what we're doing.
If I wanted to see you guys destroyed,
I'd stay silent, not sound the alarm.
I'd just let keep I just let people keep
thinking that they're okay. Adventism
isn't leading up to a false Christ, a
false gospel.
You guys bear false witness about
Christians violating the ninth
commandment constantly. It's hardcoded
into your system.
You claim we're going to hunt you down
one day and violate the sixth
commandment as stooges of the
government.
This is coming from your guys's inspired
pen. You claim we're Babylon, rejected
by God. Jesus is angry with us. Our
prayers are an abomination. We're
deceived by Satan. And the wrath of God
is kindled toward us. We're part of the
wicked world.
The actual body of Christ, the universal
body of believers that you guys claim to
be separate and distinct from as the
remnant out of that.
I I mean, by definition, the SDA church
is an accuser of the brethren. I I mean,
come on. You guys think that because you
go to church on Saturday, that somehow
makes you commandment keepers? No, it
doesn't. No, it doesn't. Are you
deceived?
You don't earn immunity by simply going
to church on Saturday, sir. And to top
it all off, you're heralding a false
gospel
that God says anyone who does so is
under a curse. Galatians 1 6-9.
You can't possibly be God's chosen,
the apple of his eye. You guys are under
God's curse, which is why we're
concerned about you, sir. And you're
going to go on to claim that we're just
weirdos on the internet.
Folks, this is spiritual warfare. I had
somebody comment today. They're like,
"Where is the where's the joy? Where's
the peace? I'm not like this 247."
When the camera is rolling and this
platform is recording, this is spiritual
warfare.
You're not out on the spiritual
battlefield hunky dory, just walking
around, eyes glazed over. No, that's not
what's going on right now. We're
concerned about you, sir.
Can you hear it in my voice? I'm not
angry. I'm concerned about you. I care
about Adventists.
Your own publications, as we're going to
see in a moment, one example out of
many, they state that you guys believe
Revelation 14 to be referring to a
message distinct to you guys that not
even the apostles preached. I mean,
hello.
That's concerning, sir.
It's a different gospel than what Paul
and the apostles preached, what Jesus
revealed to them. Galatians 1:12.
The same Paul that says there's only one
gospel, not a limited one and a full one
like you guys love to try and tout. No,
there's only one. There's not a full one
and a half one.
And if it's different than what Jesus
revealed to the apostles, it's cursed.
According
to you guys, Paul was preaching a
limited gospel
because he wasn't heralding anything
about Protestants and Catholics and a
health message in the 1844 investigative
judgment and seven steps through the
sanctuary and so on.
None of that stuff is the good news
about the person and work of Jesus.
That's the gospel.
The everlasting gospel of Revelation 14
is not a different special one-of-a-kind
gospel that's more full than what the
apostles themselves preached
as some sort of present truth message at
the end of time for a special group of
of people to take to the rest of the
world, including those of us who
supposedly only have a limited gospel as
your scholars assert.
You claim this special message that only
you guys have is a last final
proclamation of the world. Again, sir,
this is the great controversy theme
clouding your vision. Where does the
text say this?
Your prophetus who you think was just as
inspired and authoritative as the Bible
said that
that's not the Bible.
your your movement's pioneers said that,
but the Bible doesn't say that.
Not just that, but the text says nothing
about what you guys claim the angels
messages are about.
We are still waiting on you guys to be
able to show us anything about leaving
Protestantism, embracing Ellen White's
health message, embracing Ellen White
herself as a prophet who Jesus was
supposedly speaking through. That the
seventh day Sabbath is a seal of God and
the new creation memorial that Jesus
himself instituted with his own
disciples is going to be the mark of the
beast one day and so on.
This is all extra biblical great
controversy worldview nonsense that
you're then filtering the text through
thinking you have an infallible
interpreter of the Bible.
But then you cited 1 Peter 2:9, John
15:16, and verses that that use the word
chosen. Sir,
none of those writers are talking about
the SDA church.
The royal priesthood of believers is the
universal body, not your denomination.
Not a single one of those has anything
to do with the SDA church being chosen
by God to herald a last day message to
the world that no one else has.
Anyone
could pick up the Bible and do what you
just did and make the text about
themselves. And people do.
There's all sorts of people with their
own private interpretations,
completely denuted from history and
those that came before them as though
Christianity is some modern construct
that isn't 2,000 years old.
They do the same thing you just did. And
it amazes me how anacronism just
naturally flows in the SDA way of
reading the Bible.
It's like all of a sudden in the 1800s
the entire Bible has this new sort of
gnostic meaning where only you guys are
able to conveniently understand it.
Peter was writing about the church
universal sir. all believers at all
times and places who are attached to the
Lord Jesus Christ by faith. Not a single
organizational group or denomination.
Jesus in John 15 is saying the same
thing just like he said back in John 6,
John 10.
Conveniently, you guys completely ignore
that he said those whom he has chosen
are those whom the father has given him
and he'll lose none but raise them up on
the last day.
and that he says it's the father's will
that he lose none that have been given
to him.
Yet you guys claim he does which means
Jesus fails to do the will of the
father.
I I mean you even cited Romans 8:28.
The irony. Yet, if you look at it
contextually, folks, get your Bible out.
Open up your esord, whatever it may be.
This is after Paul has already laid out
such an apologetic that just I mean,
chapter and verse divisions are a 1500
edition. They're a great marker to be
able to point to like somewhere that
you're referring to, not to build entire
systems of theology off of.
He's going to go on to say later, "The
only approved hermeneutic in the SDA
church is the historical grammatical
method of interpretation." Then, Ted,
why aren't you using it? You didn't use
the HGM just now, just citing these
random verses.
Open up your Bible. Go to Romans 8. If
you look at it contextually, look at
what Paul says regarding the chosen.
This is just one example.
Romans 8:28-30.
And we know that those who love God, all
things work together for their good.
For those who are called according to
his purpose. That's what Ted read. But
Ted, why did you skip where he he uses
the word called again in verse 30? For
those whom he forneew, he also
predestined to be conformed to the image
of his son
in order that he might be the firstborn
among many brothers.
The video on Monday, folks, is going to
get into this more. Hebrews 2 talks
about Jesus. The prophets foretold that
the Messiah would be our brother,
the firstborn, the first fruits of uh
we're going to get into that later, too.
All this stuff is connected.
And those whom he predestined, he also
called. There it is, Ted.
But notice the chain of things here,
folks. And those whom he called, he also
justified. So if you're called, you're
justified.
And those whom he justified, he also
glorified.
So if you're called, Ted,
you're also justified. And if you're
called and justified, you're also
glorified.
Notice the chain of events.
Why did you ignore verse 30? The word
chosen's using again, Ted. Used again,
Ted.
Because if you guys actually executed
the Bible and didn't bounce all over the
place,
you'd see that those who are chosen are
a part of a chain of events that all
come about.
That's the chain of things that happen
to a person who is called. It's not just
some generic thing. It's not talking
about the SDA church.
This is why systematic theology
people can say what they want about, oh,
there's there's all these dangers of
systematizing scripture and yada yada.
Well, okay. But this is why it's
actually valuable. Cuz if you look at
what all of scripture says on the topic,
you'll see it's actually an effectual
thing.
This is because God is actually a
savior. You don't have that in
Adventism. He's trying his best, but he
can't bring it about.
He's at war with a creature.
That's not what Paul Paul didn't have
the great controversy worldview in
Romans 8.
He talks about an actual savior that
changes people. He actually saves
people. He doesn't try his best but
can't achieve what he desires like in
your guys's framework where one of the
heavenly trio's creatures is actually
able to thwart his desires. No, God
isn't a is a powerful capable savior. I
mean, you literally cited John 6:14.
Again, folks, go and read Jesus's
encounter in John 16 contextually. See
what's being said.
It is nothing like the SDA church's
system of theology. It destroys their
idea that man is neutral, being pulled
in two directions in a great controversy
between Christ and Satan.
It even refutes their false view of the
Lord's Supper.
These are not verses, Ted, that support
your guys' system whatsoever.
But because the word chosen appears that
somehow supports the idea that the SDA
church is God's chosen people and
Revelation 12:17 is all about you.
Ted is engaging in hopscotch exes Jesus,
which if it were an Olympic sport, the
SDA church would take the gold.
The spirit of prophecy is very clear on
this point. Testimonies for the church,
volume 7, page 138.
Seventh day Adventists have been chosen
by God as a peculiar people, separate
from the world. By the great cleaver of
truth, he has cut them out from the
quarry of the world.
It's like a a mine, like a place where
rock is collected.
and brought them into connection with
himself. He has made them his
representatives and has called them to
be ambassadors for him in the last work
of salvation. The greatest wealth of
truth ever entrusted to mortals. The
most solemn and fearful warnings ever
sent by God to man have been committed
to them to be given to the world. So
brothers and sisters, fellow leaders,
and those watching on live streaming,
wherever you may be, we have been chosen
for mission.
You can't see it too well. Perhaps we
should have featured it a little more.
It says chosen for mission.
Our special theme for this annual
council. Now, in testimonies for the
church, volume nine, one of my favorite
quotations, it's been used before in the
last few days. I want to tell you what a
blessing it's been to be part of the
annual council this year. The amazing
leadup many of you were not with us.
Last Sabbath, Sunday, Monday, the
general conference and division officers
met in this room in the room upstairs
focusing upon the beautiful, beautiful
truths of God's word.
We prayed together. We focused on some
of the truths that are being attacked.
It was a precious experience.
In fact, in the future, we're going to
spend more time studying the word of God
as general conference and division
officers and praying together to remind
ourselves of this amazing biblical
truth.
Thank you for the wonderful lead
conference, for the amazing mission trip
that we took last night, for the Sabbath
school this morning. Brothers and
sisters, we have been enriched
and we have our annual council
continuing tomorrow through Wednesday.
We have packed this annual council
with mission because we are chosen for
mission.
Volume nine, page 19. In a special
sense, seventh day Adventists have been
set in the world as watchmen and
lightbearers. To them has been entrusted
the last warning for a perishing world.
On them is shining wonderful light from
the word of God. They have been given a
work of the most solemn import. The
proclamation of the first, second, and
third angel's messages.
There is no other work of so great
importance. They are to allow nothing
else to absorb their attention. So my
friends, this is why the 7th Day
Adventist Church exists and has been
chosen to proclaim the three angels
messages on God's mission.
Ah, so now we see, like I said, this
isn't coming from scripture.
It's coming from Ellen White.
Scripture nowhere states, Ted, that
there will be a people at the end of
time that are uniquely chosen by God to
take a special one-of-a-kind present-
truth message to the world.
Nowhere does it state that in the 1800s
began the period of the last days.
Especially considering the the author of
Hebrews says, "In these last days, God
has spoken to us through his son." That
was written long before the 1800s, sir.
But notice, folks, the Ellen White quote
states that the Adventists are God's
ambassadors in the last work of
salvation.
Salvation.
So salvation supposedly hinges on this
special message they only have.
We get Adventists on this platform that
claim I'm misrepresenting Adventism by
claiming they teach you have to believe
their entire novel message hook, line,
and sinker to be saved. Here you go,
Adventist. Listen to your divinely
inspired prophetus. She's who the SDA
church claims corrects inaccurate
interpretations of scripture.
She holds the keys of authority. Not
you, not Ted Wilson, not your SDA
pastor.
And yes, your church teaches we are all
damned if we don't accept your novel
message after hearing it.
regardless of how many flaws and holes
it has that can be demonstrated and
justified.
Just go to our website, folks, if you
want to claim I know nothing about
Adventism, that literally none of the
holes that I'm able to point out are
valid.
I I mean, okay,
if we don't surrender our critical
thinking and reasoning to this message,
salvation is not ours supposedly.
She claims the greatest wealth of truth
ever entrusted to mortals.
The most solemn and fearful warnings
ever sent by God have been committed to
the SDA church. I mean, what a claim.
You know, you get Adventists that are
like, "Every denomination has their
flaws." They're not making claims like
this, folks.
Yeah, you're going to be under the
microscope when you're claiming to be
given the theory of everything.
The great controversy theme. We've
looked at this I don't know how many
times on the channel. They think they've
been given the the equivalent of the God
particle. I mean, come on. Are you
kidding me?
Yet countless SDAs want to try and claim
her writings are not elevated or treated
like scripture. This is why we're
critical of your movement when you claim
to be given the theory of everything.
What their scholars claim the great
controversy theme is. And it's supposed
to be the antidote to theological
division and confusion. correcting
everyone else with a thus sayeth the
Lord level correction. You bet we're
going to be hyperritical.
I mean, hello,
no one else is making this claim. This
is an insane claim to make.
He emphasizes their slogan of their
upcoming GC session, chosen for mission.
That's the whole he's going to say that
like 500 times throughout this thing.
And then he cites testimonies volume 9.
Adventists, this is part of why we do
not consider you part of the body of
Christ. You have your own mission. It's
not the same mission as the Christian
church. You're not just another
denomination.
You only pull that card out when you
want to be accepted and try to make
inroads to begin proitizing us.
You don't have the same mission that
Jesus left the disciples with. It can't
be.
It's a message that wasn't given to the
apostles and handed down to us today.
It's a uniquely given message to you
guys alone.
The mission the apostles were sent out
to take was supposedly a limited gospel.
According to the SDA church,
one of the hallmark signs of every cult
group is that they claim to have a
special message that only they've been
given
through their supposed prophet to take
to everyone else. They all say this.
It's a hallmark red flag sign of every
cult. God's given us some special
revelation only we have and you have to
believe it.
Ted loves to hold up his Bible and claim
the SDA message and mission is a
biblically rich message. Ted, what you
guys mean is you can quote mine verses
from around the Bible out of context
like you just did,
completely ignoring what's actually in
view and deriving the application based
on that.
That's not exesus, sir.
That's not Bible study.
It doesn't make your claims in line with
scripture just because Ellen White
claimed you guys are chosen and then you
proof text any verse you can find that
speaks of God choosing or electing
people.
So Christians understand that's how that
works for them. That's what they
consider being biblical.
As he said, the SDA mission is to herald
their novel three angels messages, none
of which are actually found in
Revelation 14, but are imported by means
of Ellen White claiming that's what the
text has in view.
Again, Revelation 14 had application
before the SDA church was even in
existence.
Mission has always been a part of the
Seventh Day Adventist Church. The first
missionary to be sent from the church
was John Neans Andrews, one of the
finest biblical scholars the church has
ever produced.
He was also a general conference
president.
Today we are celebrating the 160th
anniversary of the organizing of the
General Conference itself
in 1863
and the 100th
150th anniversary next year in 2024
of
the formal church mission service by the
Andrews family. You see, we have been
chosen for mission. Since that that
time, the church has globally grown
exponentially with missionaries going
from everywhere to everywhere. Over 22
million members and local missionaries.
Everyone is a missionary for Christ.
God's global work is flourishing because
we are chosen for mission. Nothing can
stop God's mission. Isaiah 55:11,
"So shall my word be that go that goes
forth from my mouth. It shall not return
to me void, but it shall accomplish what
I please, and it shall prosper in the
thing for which I sent it." So when you
go on God's mission, proclaiming his
word, you will not fail.
Oh, brother.
He mentions Jay and Andrews as the first
missionary of the SDA church. Ted,
you're gonna go off in a minute about
anti-heavenly trio folks in your
movement and people needing to keep an
eye out for them.
Sir,
JN Andrews was an anti-heavenly trio
guy.
And I say that purposely because the
heavenly trio isn't the trinity even
though he was against that too.
The heavenly trio is just as bad as Jane
Andrews semi-aranism. Notice JN Andrews
review and herald
March 6, 1855. Look what he says. Quote,
"The doctrine of the trinity which was
established in the church by the council
of Nika AD 325. Not true. This doctrine
destroys the personality of God and his
son Jesus Christ, our Lord.
The infamous measures by which it was
forced upon the church, which appear
upon the pages of ecclesiastical
history, might well cause every believer
in that doctrine to blush.
Close quote.
Another quote, same guy.
And as to the son of God, he would be
excluded also. For he had God for his
father and did some point at eternity uh
of the past at the eternity of the past
have beginning of days.
So that if we use Paul's language in an
absolute sense, it would be impossible
to find but one being in the universe
and that is God the Father who is
without father or mother or descent or
beginning of days or end of life. Close
quote. Review and Herald September 7,
1869.
This is one of the best biblical
scholars your church has ever produced.
I mean my goodness, man.
It's no wonder these pioneers were
confused though. They thought the
heavenly trio that you guys proitized is
the trinity.
They didn't even understand the basic
language used in the Nyine and Athanian
creeds.
And we're against something that's not
even being claimed in those creeds. Like
that trinitarians supposedly don't
believe Jesus is truly the son of God
despite the Aanian creed for example
explicitly referring to Jesus as the
son.
I mean it's just laughable. Again these
folks think they have the theory of
everything given to them by God himself
to be able to know with absolute
certainty everything that can be known
about the mind of God. That's what
Herbert Douglas says.
Then he claims the SDA church is
flourishing.
Ted, I think you confused two words
here.
Flourishing is not the same as
floundering.
You guys are losing almost half of your
people every year. That's coming from
your own sources, sir.
Since 1965. This is from last this past
general conference session update from
David Trim, your own guys head of your
your own person. Uh that's head of
statistics.
Since 1965, sir, 45.6 million people
were baptized into the SDA church. 45.6
million.
But notice, you claimed you guys have 22
million worldwide.
That's because at least 18.5 million
have left, which is a net loss rate of
42.5%.
If you guys were actually busting at the
seams like you publicly like to portray,
you wouldn't be ready. You wouldn't be
getting ready to give your classic uh
escathing rebuke to the members about
not doing enough. like at the San
Antonio General Conference or the
General Session
where you're raking Adventists across
the coals saying if they had done their
job, Jesus would have returned by now,
which is in effect what you're going to
launch into in this speech as well.
Now, the devil tries everything to
hinder the mission of the church today,
including violence. Just heard about it
today. hostile environments,
persecution,
discouragement,
confusion,
internal bickering,
distractions,
false doctrines,
attacks against God's people.
Let me tell you,
this is a very handy device.
But if you were here this morning,
you heard Melody Mason say, "We need to
surrender these to God
because they can be so destructive."
You go online, you can hear all kinds of
weird things
about church leaders
and about me.
Well, I want to tell you, we don't worry
about that because we're chosen for
mission.
So, we have internal and external
disagreements and denigration of the
word of God.
Ted, where are Seventh Day Adventists
being persecuted?
Seriously, where
we always hear this language thrown
around like SDAs are some endangered
people group.
What persecution are SDAs facing?
What you guys really mean, because I
hear it all the time, is that your
theology is critically examined and
critiqued, which you guys label as
attack and persecution,
which is rich considering that would
mean by your own standards, you guys
have to be the biggest persecutor and
attacker of Christians worldwide. It's
hardcoded into your movement.
Your prophetist claims our prayers are
an abomination to God. God's rejected us
for rejecting your novel message.
Jesus looks at us with displeasure. Our
churches are filled with evil angels
masquerading as Christians. Satan's
taken control of our churches. Were
worse than heathen. We're a part of the
wicked world. And on and on and on.
This is another classic case of the
catch22 double standard you guys are
caught in. It's attack and persecution
from Satan. When someone critiques your
theology, yet you guys love critiquing
everyone else's theology.
No one's persecuting you guys, sir.
Christians in the Middle East and
Nigeria and elsewhere. That's who's
persecuted.
Beheaded for the Lord Jesus Christ, not
the Sabbath, not for the SDA message,
for the true gospel and faith in the
person and work of Jesus.
And it's shameful that you try and
position the SDA church as some mass
martyr complex.
You guys are supposedly going to take a
stand one day for the 7th day Sabbath,
but can't even handle someone critically
examining your beliefs. That is not a
good sign. You mentioned the SDA church
or that SDAs go online and hear all
sorts of weird things about SDA uh
church leaders. Ah, you mean answering
Adventism, Ted?
Yes, we're here. We're not going
anywhere, my friend.
You say you aren't worried about it, but
the time will come when you can't just
dismiss us as being some fringe keyboard
warrior platform.
We have people reaching out from
Australia, Africa, China, Belgium, all
over the globe who want to partner in
this effort,
who want to get boots on the ground
active in their countries and pull
Adventist out of the fires.
So, you can say whatever you want about
us being weird or whatever.
We're in a different era, my friend.
This is not the 1980s anymore.
You're going to have to start dealing
with the substance of what we say, not
just do drive by hit jobs thinking it's
going to keep people from hearing the
truth,
which is what your guys's MO has been
for decades.
You say you aren't worried, yet you're
mentioning it from the annual council
stage.
If you aren't worried, then why are you
even mentioning it?
Document down this stream, my friends.
document it down.
The day will come when the SDA church
gives their next report on retention
rates and answering Adventism will, by
God's provision, have been a key part in
making the numbers tank.
Not going to work anymore, sir.
And you need to learn that not all
former Adventists are the same. We don't
all share the same beliefs by virtue of
being former Adventists.
And Paul tells us in Philippians 1, I'm
not to fear enemies of the gospel
because it's a sign of your destruction,
but to us, it's a sign of our salvation.
Truth is the anvil that can wear out any
hammer, which is why we aren't afraid of
any of your theology. And I concede
personally nothing to you guys, as
you're going to see momentarily. Not the
Sabbath, not the law, none of it. And
your guys' apologists, recycled
arguments from the pioneers are not
going to work on this platform and our
positions.
I'll tell you this morning as we
proceed, I'm going to be really focusing
on that particular area. the denigration
of God's word, the neutralization
of God's word, and all kinds of other
angry assaults, including misinformation
and outright false allegations against
God's work. You know, various people or
organizations, they they attack God's
church, twisting facts and
misrepresenting the very character of
God's remnant church. There seem to be
people who just specialize in that. They
just live to make others look bad.
Ted, you just got done saying you're not
worried about us and here you are
continuing to do damage control.
Are you sure you're not worried, my
friend?
Doesn't sound like it.
Sounds like you're projecting and have
to do uh h damage control which is why
you're making a public statement at the
annual council to tell people to not
listen to us.
And I know you guys are aware of this
platform considering you've sent liaison
individuals to our email who then lie
and claim they're going to do things
they end up not doing.
You guys know who you are.
But Ted, these sorts of cryptic warnings
are not going to work anymore.
Deal with the substance of what is
presented. You guys are not prepared for
what's coming.
Not because I'm some amazing person
because I'm not. I don't have my own
private interpretations, my own private
understandings. Like I've cracked some
code that no one else understood before
me.
But you guys are not prepared. I've
scoured your guys' barrii, the Biblical
Research Institute, the Adventist Barri.
You guys are not prepared, sir.
And your your your ad homonym defense
and claiming we're confused, m
misrepresenting, twisting the facts, and
all the other lame excuses you've used
for decades. They're not going to work
anymore, sir.
People are seeing through it. People can
examine what we say and show on this
platform and reason for them for
themselves to see who has and hasn't
done their homework.
You don't want to name us because you
don't want SDAs looking into who we are
and sending people our way and what
we're saying.
If we're so confused and misrepresenting
and totally clueless,
then why aren't you guys able to squash
what we're doing? should be simple,
right?
You claim those of us that are
critiquing your movement live to make
others look bad. The irony.
The irony. Your movement is built on
this, sir.
You guys misrepresent Catholics and
Protestants all the time.
You lie and claim we believe things we
don't. Like that we think humans have
natural immortality when no, only God
has that. and we believe he sustains the
souls of individuals as the sovereign.
You misrepresent why we worship on the
first day claiming it's because of the
papacy when no it's because the Lord
Jesus who instituted such practice after
his resurrection with the apostles
who then continued that practice and
handed it down to us today.
These misrepresentations are hardcoded
into your guys' theology. You just
referenced Jay and Andrews moments ago
and he did exactly that in his
fictitious book, The History of the
Sabbath.
Hypocrisy is a sin. I know it's not
stated in the Ten Commandments,
but yes, it's a sin.
And it seems to be a constant problem
with you guys.
It's almost comical that when the tables
are turned on you guys and people begin
examining you more closely, you want to
pull out the martyr card and claim we're
misrepresenting, lying, confused, live
to attack others.
No, we care about 7th Adventists enough
to tell them the truth,
to warn them about the wrath to come for
all those that are not found in the true
Christ.
and that the Seventh Advenist Church has
a false is a false church with a false
Christ, a false gospel, and it's built
upon a false prophet.
We're not going anywhere, Ted. This
train's just getting started. I waited
10 years to start answering Adventism. I
didn't do so hastily.
I sought godly counsel, prayed, studied,
prepared, and now is the big dance. It
was all leading to this.
You're going to name us by name one day,
sir. Not because I want some sort of
clout or recognition,
but because at that point, we'll know
you have no other choice because our
impact will have been so big that you
have to.
And it's our hypothesis, document this
down, folks, that you'll use the same
playbook you always have by getting your
scholars together to formulate a hit
piece, put it out, thinking it will stop
the train, but it'll be too late.
By that point, we'll be moving at such a
fast pace, we'll blast through that
paper barrier.
It's not going to work anymore, sir.
We are going to be a voice for all the
people you guys have spiritually
disenfranchised and left spiritually
orphaned and confused from all the
theological fog that you guys have
produced while simultaneously raising
the awareness of the body of Christ and
your sheepstealing tactics and equip
more Christians to reach Adventists with
the truth. And I mean that. I'm not just
trying to be some shock jock online.
We're committed here, folks.
We're building a team of people.
We're growing. We're reaching
international heights.
And it's not for patting ourselves on
the back to say, "Oh, yeah. It's
amazing." No, we're pulling people out
of the fire.
This is spiritual warfare. We got
bullets whizzing past our head, putting
our own lives on the line, sacrificing
our own uh careers, our own time.
It's not just about getting clicks on
the internet.
This is a war.
And you can get on stage and make these
these claims and these statements. It's
not slowing down.
It is not slowing down, sir. We don't
hate you. We don't hate Seventh Day
Adventist. But yeah, we're serious here.
I've said it, folks, for a long time.
We are not the kitchen of the
battlefield or back in the back in the
camp.
We are a frontline activity.
We're intents here. Yeah, there's a time
and a place for that. I'm not like this
all the time.
This is boots strapped on, helmet
strapped on, crawling through the
trenches with gashes in our face
while the devil is trying to take people
to hell.
And we're trying to spit on his face and
pull people out of the fire and say,
"Screw you. We're going to pull people
out of this deception."
Now in the written
presentations there will be more
references backup etc than today. Today
I'm just going to share with you
specific
indications in my sermon. We're also
producing and will be producing short
videos to help our church members
worldwide know Bible truth and where we
stand on issues and that we are focused
on God's final commission since we are
chosen for mission.
Now, please
carefully take note
of these following confusing
interruptions
by the devil.
And I want to tell you, I am not placing
myself before you today
as the ultimate answer to all of these
items.
I am sharing with you from my heart
today
because you as church leaders
and God's people need to know where we
stand today. Number one, a lack of
understanding
the Bible,
how to interpret it, and antagonism
against the very word of God.
You see, the Seventh Day Adventist
Church believes in the authenticity and
authority of God's word, the Holy Bible,
and it is to be applied to all people
everywhere for all time.
The church accepts only, I want to
underline that, only the historical,
biblical, or historical grammatical
method of interpreting scripture,
allowing the Bible to interpret itself,
line upon line, verse upon verse,
precept upon precept, through the power
of the Holy Spirit. Now, let me warn
you, and I've done this before, but I
want you to get it into your mind. We
are under attack by the historical
critical method or any other method of
biblical interpretation
which is unacceptable to seventh day
Adventists because those methods are not
godfocused methods but rather
humanistic.
You see, you become
the determiner in the historical
critical method
of determining what is truth and what is
not.
But I urge you, allow the Holy Spirit to
lead you in understanding scripture. Use
only the historicist approach when
understanding biblical prophecies. Not
the predtoist, not the futurist, but the
historical.
The spirit of prophecy indicates that we
should read the Bible as it reads.
Spiritual gifts, page 94, indicates,
"God has given sufficient evidence upon
which to base faith if he wish to
believe. In the last days, the earth
will be almost destitute of true faith.
Upon the meest pretense, the word of God
will be considered unreliable, while
human reasoning will be received, though
it be in opposition to plain scripture
facts.
Do not be influenced by those who in the
church
ignore, denigrate, or depreciate
the word of God.
The 7th Day Adventist Church membership
and its leadership stands strongly on a
clear understanding and acceptance of
the entire word of God as it reads.
All right. So, get that.
This is where the SDA church stands.
Some Adventists love to claim Adventism
is a big tent with lots of varying
viewpoints and ideas.
It's just some ecumenical bastion of
diversity of thought. Nope. Sorry,
friend.
That's the exact opposite of Adventism.
Adventism was founded upon 100% knowing
exactly who they were, what their
mission was,
what the old landmarks of truth, as
Ellen White called them, what those were
and that they supposedly have. This
modern spin on Adventism to try and
shift with the culture is exactly that,
a modernist spin.
Ted, I'm in agreement. You guys have
people in your ranks that want to
distort this reality and act like it
isn't true. So, for that, you should
thank this platform
because we want your members to own what
you are openly stating.
But Ted, it's also funny to hear you
state like you did at last year's annual
council
that the only method of interpretation
that you guys accept is the historical
grammatical method of interpretation.
Sir, you just got done utilizing
some other total some hopscotch method
by proof texting from all over the place
completely ignoring the historicity of
the text to then derive your application
from.
You guys don't utilize the HGM when
interpreting Revelation.
You completely denude the book from
history and insert all sorts of novel
concepts and ideas into the text
anacronistically.
How you can claim you guys utilize the
HGM is one of the biggest head
scratchers.
For those that don't know, the
historical grammatical method of
interpretation is when you discover the
meaning of the passage as the original
author would have intended and what the
original hearers would have understood
and then derived today's application
from that.
Is that what you heard Ted define it as?
He inserts their novel idea that Ellen
White and William Miller gave them of
hopscotching around the Bible
and then they call that letting the
Bible interpret itself and equate that
with the HGM when no Ted, that isn't
what the HGM is.
You have to utilize the original
audience and derive the author's
intended meaning out of the text and
then deduce modern-day application
to utilize the HGM. You guys don't do
this ever. I have yet to see it.
It's always some anacronistic reading
into the Bible ideas that the great
controversy worldview presents, jumping
all over the Bible, and then claiming
that somehow proves your position.
But Avenous, there you go. The only
accepted method of interpretation by the
SDA church is the HGM.
So you guys have to demonstrate for us
that when John the Revelator was writing
the revelation
that he and the original audience would
have understood, for example, Revelation
14 to be some novel end time special
truth message that would begin in the
19th century
that denominations are a tool of Satan
which was supposedly told uh in
Revelation 6 like we saw a few weeks ago
responding to Ted Wilson and so on.
Let's see it.
Ted claims that any other method of
interpretation is humanistic. Ted,
you guys, you utilize a method that's
humanistic.
It's one of the most man- centered
readings of scripture I've ever heard.
It centers around reading yourself and
your movement into all parts of the
Bible. You just demonstrated this for us
not even 10 minutes prior. You read a
bunch of verses that talk about being
chosen
and then make that exclusively about the
SDA church.
You didn't utilize the HGM when doing
that.
You guys do exactly what the higher
critical method does.
You determine what is truth and what is
not. Or rather Ellen White does.
You literally have an entire doctrine
around present truth.
And then you just veil it behind. No,
no, no. It's Jesus speaking through
Ellen White. It's him. It's him that's
telling us this.
But then when things don't work out
according to plan, like how you're
celebrating 160 years of incorporation,
you just pivot and truth changes to fit
with whatever you guys decide.
I I find it really hard to believe that
you can be this unaware. It does not add
up.
This talk is mirroring last year's
annual council speech almost to a tea so
far. But furthermore, Ted,
you guys claim to have the great
controversy theme, which is supposed to
be the antidote for theological
confusion and division.
Yet here you are warning about such
things. Why is the great controversy
theme constantly failing at showing all
these divisionaries the truth and
getting them back on track?
Why are there leaders in your church
that aren't able to be clearly shown the
mind of God as you guys have called the
great controversy theme?
I thought theological division was a
hallmark of Babylon.
Does that mean you guys fit your own
definition?
Time to wake up, my friend. Smell the
coffee. The alarm is sounding.
And then he claims, now folks, this is
going to be a theme throughout the
entire talk. He claims SDAs just read
the Bible as it is.
Ted, if you guys read the Bible as it
reads, you'd never come to the
conclusion that Revelation 14 is about
1844 and the investigative judgment and
Protestants needing to come join you
guys. That the everlasting gospel is a
novel, present truth, special end times
message that only you guys have. That we
need to embrace Ellen White's health
reform, her writings themselves. And
there's going to be a national turned
international Sunday law that's the mark
of the beast. that the seventh day
Sabbath is the seal of God, that the
fourth commandment has a halo around it
in heaven, or any of the other stuff
that you guys read into the text.
The fact that you guys think your system
is strictly derived from the Bible is
laughable.
And I don't mean like haha poking fun at
you. I mean it's sad.
Your own publications
state that one can't even understand the
Bible without the great controversy
theme to interpret it for you.
Your own Sabbath school quarterlys say
that Ellen White's the infallible
interpreter of the infallible Bible. I
mean, give me a break.
Shoot. Sorry, folks. Gotta jump back up
here. Let's see.
of God as it reads.
Number two, confusion and misinformation
about the Godhead and the Trinity.
Let me tell you
probably after this sermon
Magdal
Perez Schulz my extremely able assistant
he's the one who receives or Marilyn
Perez my executive assistant they will
receive
messages
why did Wilson say that Wilson is wrong
I want to tell you Today
I am telling you
from my perspective
what the Bible says
the trinity 7th adventist believe there
is one God and that this one God is
three co-eternal persons who work
together in unity.
We fully embrace our fundamental belief
number two, which indicates that the
father, the son, and the holy spirit
have always been and always will be.
Make no mistake about it. The divine
trinity work in unison as one within the
godhead from eternity to eternity.
Allow God to use you, every one of you,
to share this wonderful truth of a
triune God who is carrying out his plan
of salvation for each of us.
Ted, you were literally just praising JN
Andrews as the SDA church's first
missionary, one of the best theologians
ever produced by the SDA church. The guy
was an anti-trinitarian heretic.
You said you believe the father, son,
and spirit have always been and always
will be. Yet, as we saw, Jay and Andrews
said the exact opposite. Sir, the people
you're warning about in your movement
today are appealing to people like him
and the other pioneers to support their
position.
This is why you guys are in such a mess.
Your pioneers were not qualified to be
teaching anyone about scripture.
If swing and a miss were a theological
system, the one they came up with fits
the bill perfectly.
And it's because of their confusion and
claiming everyone else was wrong and
they were here to correct everyone else
that people in your movement today
inherited that mess.
The entire reason you're having to give
this section of your presentation is due
to the seeds sewn by your own pioneers.
This also shows you aren't the
commandment keepers. By the way, you
guys can't even agree on who God is.
And what you guys claim the trinity is
isn't even the triune God.
It is a triistic monarchian hybrid
concept that you've branded as the
Trinity.
Yet your scholars and publications
openly state that you guys oppose nying
credto trinitarianism.
You simply latched on to Christian
language to try and appear within
orthodoxy.
The way that you guys use the term God
is also part of the problem.
You guys don't mean one singular
ultimate being that is expressed in
three persons that are co-eternal and
co-equal.
You guys use person and being
interchangeably. They're not the same. A
chair has being. It doesn't have
personhood.
It's just basic language. That's why
this language is so important.
But because Ellen White used the terms
interchangeably, you guys are stuck
having to do so to say, "Well, it's the
same thing." No, it isn't. Not at all.
Inanimate objects have being. They don't
have personhood.
You guys use the term God like a
familial title, which is what's on your
website. They're like a team.
And what makes them one, as you said, is
mission and purpose.
They also all have a tangible physical
form and are made up of parts such as
hands, eyes, a nose.
And there are three of those physical
beings. That's not the trinity. You guys
need to stop using that language and
confusing people. The father, son, and
spirit in your system do not share in
the same attributes. Even Jesus isn't
omnipresent. for example.
So, while you're lambasting the
anti-heavenly trio adherence in your
ranks, you yourselves have a false god.
You have two different idols that are
arguing back and forth,
which again shows, no, you're not the
commandmentkeeping church.
Number three,
and this is perhaps one of the more
sensitive items today,
misunderstanding about human sexuality.
I want to absolutely
underline the fact that all of us are to
show respect and care for all people.
But the Bible,
this precious word of God is clear on
what God's instructions are regarding
human sexuality.
The Bible indicates that marriage is
only,
let me underline that again, only
between one man and one woman.
aberrations in human sexuality are not
acceptable to God. And let's not just
focus on LGBTQ.
It includes adultery,
lentiousness,
bestiality,
homosexuality,
and other alternative
unbiblical
LGBTQ
sexual activities which
the Bible indicates, including all of
those those aspects of human sexuality
which are against God's word, they are
sin. Yes.
Now, before you get too
demonstrative about that,
remember we are all sinners at the foot
of the cross.
So, when we're dealing with these
situations,
deal with love, with care, with respect,
but know what the Bible says.
Unfortunately, some individuals today,
even within the Seventh Day Adventist
Church,
and we have some situations,
we're working with
two
divisions and their administrations
to care for current challenges in this
area. But let me tell you, none of you
in all the world divisions are immune to
this.
But some people are twisting the word of
God, such as Romans 1:es
18 through32.
Now, we're not going to go over that
today, but some people are advocating
that it says what it does not say and
does not say what it says.
Read the Bible as it reads.
I want to tell you the church, the
worldwide 7th Adventist Church does not
and will not accept individuals as
church members or elected church leaders
who are not adhering to the biblical
understanding and practice of biblical
human sexuality.
Do not bend to anyone who misuses the
Bible and its heavenly instructions
found in Romans chapter 1 18-32,
Leviticus 18:32, Leviticus 20:13, and
many, many other texts.
You see, God's
word asks us
to stand firm for what he has indicated
as Bible truth on this subject and many
other subjects. As with any sinful
practice, as outlined in the scriptures,
we are to help people who come to our
churches, pointing them to the foot of
the cross where they can find full
forgiveness and a new life in Christ. As
2 Corinthians
5 and verse 17 tells us, we can become
new creatures in Jesus.
all sinners at the foot of the cross,
Ted.
That doesn't comport with your guys'
system, as we're going to see later. But
I'll give him credit.
At least he's bold enough to take the
the stance of what scripture does indeed
say about marriage and human sexuality,
which is obviously a golden calf of our
day, so to speak, that tends to get
somebody shouted down by the mob for
stating. But again, Ted,
you guys aren't supposed to have
theological division.
That's supposed to be reserved for us
apostate Protestants who are totally
deceived and completely confused by the
devil. You're supposed to have the great
controversy theme, which is the antidote
to all of that.
Why are there leaders in your movement
that support such behaviors?
not just simply recognize that people
struggle with sin, but actively promote
theological liberalism.
You said these people twist the word of
God to fit their views.
Why isn't the great controversy theme
able to fix all that, sir?
Why are the hallmarks of Babylon, in
this case theological division, rearing
their head in your own ranks? Your own
universities are embracing this stuff.
I've seen the receipts.
I was there. I was a student in in one
of your universities.
Yet you guys claim part of the
identifying mark of your your being a a
peculiar people is that you don't have
all that. You're united like Jesus said
his disciples were to be.
But then you mentioned 2 Corinthians
5:17. Boy, I'm going to be harping on
this a lot tonight, folks. Just wait and
buckle up until later.
My my the irony,
Ted. It's 2 Corinthians 5 that
demonstrates we're in the new creation,
not the old.
Which if you guys understood, you'd
realize why you're clinging to the old
creation memorial, which is erroneous.
2 Corinthians 5:17 isn't only about
behavior modification.
It says new creature. Some translations
will say new creation.
Behavior isn't a creature, Ted.
Behavior is the fruit that creatures
exhibit.
When a person is made a new creature,
regenerated, born again,
there's actually an aspect of their
being that changes.
Then they await the glorification of a
resurrected body that accompanies that.
But it's the Adventist physicalist
worldview that clouds their
understanding which keeps them from
being able to see this.
The new creation was inaugurated by
virtue of Jesus accomplishing the
redemption of the creation that fell.
That was finished at his resurrection,
the final step of his redemptive work.
That includes us as well as the rest of
of creation that will one day have the
curse lifted off of it. Romans 8.
But this is why they're not able to
understand the summation statement from
Christians who say we worship on the
first day because of the resurrection.
Sabbath is tied to creation. They will
agree. Ted's actually going to say that
later.
But then we have to examine both old and
new creation.
They want to stay stuck in the old
exclusively because they have no
category for new creation being a
present reality. It's all some future
sort of pie in the sky off in the future
sort of thing.
And then in 2 Corinthians 5:17, like Ted
just did, they boil it down to
exclusively just behavioral change.
When the reality is is no, the new
creation has been inaugurated by Jesus
who accomplished the redemption of all
things.
And the new creation has a new memorial.
It's not the seventh day. That was the
memorial of the old creation. Again, if
you're an Adventist, stick around.
You want to say that's not biblical.
You're just Okay. If you think I'm
talking out the side of my neck, stick
around.
Now, I cut out some of the the rest of
of this section because he he drags on
and on and on about LGBTQ stuff, and I
want to try and get to the rest of of
what he says here.
In Colossians chapter 2 verse 8
it says beware
lest anyone cheat you
through philosophy
and empty deceit
according to the tradition of men
according to the basic principles of the
world and not according to Christ.
People will try to twist the words of
the Bible.
Pastors,
teachers,
theologians,
administrators,
even church members try to twist the
words of the Bible.
Paul tells us,
"Don't let anyone cheat you through
philosophy and empty deceit.
Stay close
to the word of God.
We have many wonderful theologians in
our church.
The Biblical Research Institute is a
wonderful organization. I have full
confidence in BRI.
I want you to have full confidence too.
We have other theologians, wonderful
deliverers of the word of God.
But there are some even within our own
ranks
who are twisting the word of God
not as it reads.
Stay away from them
in scripture. In fact, it's for our
chapter for today and believe his
prophets.
Chapter 4. Listen to this amazing
council.
Verse 23. Keep your heart with all
diligence, for out of it spring the
issues of life. Put away from you a
deceitful mouth and put perverse lips
far from you. Here it is. Let your eyes
look straight ahead
and your eyelids look right before you.
Ponder the path of your feet and let
your ways be established.
Verse 27, the last verse of that
chapter. Proverbs 4. Do not turn to the
right or the left.
Remove your foot from evil.
My fellow leaders,
church members,
theologians,
teachers, pastors,
health care workers,
publishing leaders, I don't care who you
are.
Don't get stuck in the ditches on the
right or the left.
Look straight ahead.
Do not turn to the right or the left
because you are chosen for mission.
Ted, you guys do the exact thing you're
trying to warn about.
You guys twist the scriptures to fit
with your extra biblical great
controversy worldview.
To act like you just read the Bible as
it reads is one of the most ridiculous
assertions.
The Bible says nothing about a national
Sunday law. It says nothing about
America being in revelation. It says
nothing about denominations being a tool
of Satan.
These are all things that are your
interpretation,
not just the Bible as it reads.
You guys simply think you have an
infallible interpretation of the Bible
housed in Ellen White's writings. But
no, sir, you you guys don't just read
the Bible as it is.
This is the constant double speak that
plagues your guys' movement.
You said people need to stay away from
those who are twisting the Bible. I
agree. People need to steer clear of the
Seventh Adventist Church who veils their
extra biblical worldview behind a
biblical veneer, borrowing Christian
language and concepts, but then infuses
them into the great controversy
worldview, which confuses people and
makes a total mess out of scripture.
But again, Ted, you guys aren't supposed
to have any sort of theological
confusion and division in your ranks.
You falsely characterize Protestants as
being such, and your prophetist claims
that's a hallmark sign exclusive to
Babylon,
what you guys are supposed to be
completely separate from.
I guess having the theory of everything
isn't the antidote to theological
confusion after all, is it?
He mentioned Adventist being called to
look straight ahead.
Ted, this is also ironic considering
your entire movement is predicated on
looking backward, not forward.
You guys think heaven is essentially a
return to Eden. Your prophetist calls
your ministers to point the hearers back
to the foot of Sinai. You guys uphold
the more the memorial of the old
creation over and against the new.
You point people back to the old
covenant saying basically the new
covenant's a doover of the old covenant.
Everything with you guys is going back
back back, not forward.
Now there's an audio glitch on their end
at one point um in this next part. It's
only for a few seconds. Just know that
it's not me.
If there are those
in this room
or those watching online
and there are many leaders all over the
world,
if you are unable
for some
to not
fully trust this book.
I'm not saying we don't have differences
of opinion on certain things in
scripture. Obviously, we're going to
continue to learn throughout his
throughout eternity when we get to
heaven.
I'm not talking about small issues that
each of us have disagreements on perhaps
as to a certain indication or how to
interpret it. I'm talking about our
major fundamental beliefs, 28 of them.
And I'm talking about reading the Bible
as it reads.
If you as a leader
and I'm not only speaking to you in this
room but others who may be watching but
you represent the world leadership.
If you as a leader
cannot accept the word of God as it
reads,
I urge you to resign your position.
[Applause]
I will take that as affirmation to God's
word, not to me.
I am not wanting a purge.
I am not wanting some kind of witch
hunt.
I am wanting though and I'm speaking for
myself in my position.
I want leaders who believe 100%
in the full word of God.
[Applause]
Ouch.
There you go folks.
Avenous,
if you don't adhere to the 28
fundamental beliefs, Ted Wilson wants
you to resign.
Sounds like a whole lot of Babylon
infiltrating the SDA church, if you ask
me. Theological confusion and division
amongst their own leadership while they
hurl this accusation at Christians to
try and bolster their own system. How
ironic.
When I was on the Seeking What They Saw
podcast, for those that don't know, that
was some Adventist pastors, their
podcast,
it was for a series titled, "What is an
Adventist?" And the thesis was trying to
put forth this sort of Big 10 ideology
around Adventism. What was my answer?
Those of you that watched,
if you watched, you know my answer to
the question was someone who upholds the
28 fundamental beliefs.
They didn't agree with this definition
because they themselves
claim to be Adventists but aren't in
line with all 28.
This is the problem. TED knows that
Adventism is a system.
It has interconnected beliefs that rely
on one another. Those of us that have
studied systematic theology,
specifically Seventh Day Adventist
systematic theology, know this.
You can't be an allocart Adventist and
be consistent. It does not work that
way.
And here you have the president of the
SDA church recognizing that, asking
Adventist leadership that isn't in line
with that definition to step down.
Adventists, you can continue to to to
come against this platform and claim I'm
confused. No clue what I'm talking
about. I'm just a balker. I'm a scoffer.
I'm ignorant. Whatever. But understand,
some of us have done our homework.
We don't have to cheat off of our
neighbors homework to turn it in.
Some of us have actually put in the
grunt work. Others like to shoot
spitballs from the sidelines hurling
accusations
while some of us have actually done the
leg work. So remember that when you hear
and see people claim that this platform
is confused, misrepresenting, etc.,
understand that's the only defense they
have
because they haven't actually done the
homework.
The reality is is no, I understand it
very well and they don't like that
because it's going to allow for a
streamlined process of communication to
help people see the issues quickly and
get them pulled out of the fire and get
Christians caught up to speed.
We're already seeing this exact thing,
folks. We get inundated with
testimonials. I'm not just saying this.
We just got one a few days ago from a
guy in Jamaica binging our content. No
longer SDA. We get them weekly.
So, they can say what they want. I've
heard it all for years.
I'm confused. I'm dumb. I'm a Jesuit
plant. I'm taking this out of context.
I'm angry. I'm a clueless critic. And so
on.
None of that stops what's happening.
People are able to assess for
themselves, benefiting from the years of
labor that I put in over the last 10
years of study. And more and more
Christians are getting equipped to take
the truth to SDAs like never before.
Ted Wilson is giving this speech because
the movement is unraveling.
He comes across like the stern parental
figure in this presentation that's
scolding their children out of
frustration
after losing control of the ship. Maybe
it's just me, but he is in damage
control mode. He's in the same mode he
was in again at Doug Bachelor's Hold the
Line conference.
Things are not looking good for them,
folks.
Well, let's go on. Number four,
confusion on the sanctuary service and
righteousness by faith.
The earthly sanctuary service given by
Moses or given by God to Moses is a
direct copy of what is in heaven. The
earthly sanctuary service portrays the
complete plan of salvation, showing
God's great love and the centrality of
Christ's sacrifice and grace in the
salvation process. The earthly and
heavenly sanctuary services are keys to
understanding the process of salvation
based on the righteousness of Jesus
Christ.
Seventh day Adventists ought to be the
foremost in living up lifting up Jesus
and his righteousness. Never let anyone
say that we are legalists. We are full
of Christ's righteousness.
It is the very core of the three angels
messages.
The church believes that the work of the
first apartment of the sanctuary was
completed at Calvary when Christ died as
the lamb. The Bible indicates that in
1844,
Christ entered the real second apartment
of the real heavenly sanctuary to begin
the investigative judgment and is
currently interceding as our high
priest. The sanctuary service shows the
complete ministry of Christ lifting up
his justifying and sanctifying
righteousness as our only path to
eternal life. We are not saved by being
vegan.
I
Nancy and I try
95% to be vegan.
We're certainly vegetarians
which I
would offer to all of you as well.
But we're not saved by that. We're not
saved by our contribution to the general
conference treasury for the wonderful
offering for today.
We are saved by the grace
and the absolute saving power only of
Jesus Christ.
Now soon Jesus is going to leave the
most holy place of the heavenly
sanctuary. He's going to take off those
priestly robes and he's going to put on
kingly robes and he's going to come to
take us home at his second coming. What
a joy to proclaim Christ as our savior
and lord who not only saves us but helps
us to grow more and more like him all
through his power.
Okay, folks, get comfortable.
We have a lot to look at on this one.
Ted, is it really shocking that people
might be confused on the sanctuary and
investigative judgment when it's
arguably one of the most convoluted,
confusing doctrines ever thought up?
Not just that, but your prophetist
claimed
that it had to be believed in order to
be able to exercise the faith necessary
to make it through the time of trouble.
But notice what she says here. We'll get
to that quote in a moment. Notice what
she says here. Quote, this is from
Christ in his sanctuary. Page 160
through 161.
It is those who by faith follow Jesus in
the great work of the atonement who
receive the benefits of his mediation in
their behalf. While those who reject the
light which brings to view this work of
ministration are not benefited thereby.
I'm going to let that baste. This is
about the investigative judgment, folks.
Now, she does her favorite thing here of
of using the Jews as an analogy of those
who rejected the light of God and those
who rejected Christ to then claim
Christians who reject their message are
just like the Jews. The Jews who
rejected the light given at Christ's
first advent and refused to believe on
him as the savior of the world could not
receive pardon through him.
When Jesus at his ascension entered by
his own blood into the heavenly
sanctuary to shed upon his disciples the
blessings of his mediation, the Jews
were left in total darkness to continue
their useless sacrifices and offerings.
The ministration of types and shadows
had ceased. That door by which men had
formerly found access to God was no
longer open. The Jews had refused to
seek him in the only way whereby he
could then be found through the
ministration in the sanctuary in heaven.
Therefore, they found no communion with
God. To them, the door was shut. They
had no knowledge of Christ as the true
sacrifice and the only mediator before
God. Hence, they could not receive the
benefits of his mediation.
Now, get this. The condition of the
unbelieving Jews illustrates the
condition of the careless and
unbelieving among professed Christians
who are willingly ignorant of the work
of our merciful high priest.
In the typical service, when the high
priest entered the most holy place, all
Israel were were required to gather
about the sanctuary and in the most
solemn manner humble their souls before
God that they might receive the pardon
of their sins and not be cut off from
the congregation. How much more
essential is the antitypical day of
atonement that we understand the work of
our high priest and know what duties are
required of us. Close quote.
So if you reject this doctrine, you
supposedly reject the mediation of
Christ on your behalf. You are just like
the Christrejecting Jews of the first
century that missed the Messiah's
coming.
Jesus's mediation is only sufficient for
those who believe it.
Ted talked about misrepresentation
earlier.
Ted, here you go.
Rebuke your prophetus who completely
misrepresents Christians and has left
countless Adventists doing the same
thing by making this charge that
Christians don't believe Jesus is a high
priest because we reject this silly
unbiblical gospel distorting doctrine
where you guys then utilize the false
dilemma fallacy.
Either you agree with us or you insert
whatever when no the reality is there's
more than two options.
But to all the Adventists that want to
claim you're an Adventist, but you
reject this teaching, a sort of eat the
meat, spit out the bones type of
approach, no pun intended, here you go.
It's time to make a choice, friend.
And if you're one of those the the ones
that also reject Ellen White, so you say
there's something to the effect of I
don't care what she says, then you also
have to reject being the remnant church
because she's supposedly the identifying
mark of that. And brick by brick, the
entire structure comes down again. She
continues, "Christ in his sanctuary."
Next page, quote, "Men cannot with
impunity," look that word up folks,
impunity.
Men cannot with impunity reject the
warning which God in mercy sends them.
Talking about the message of the
investigative judgment.
A message was sent forth from heaven to
the world in Noah's day and their
salvation depended upon the manner in
which they treated that message. Because
they rejected the warning, the spirit of
God was withdrawn from the sinful race
and they perished in the waters of the
flood.
In the time of Abraham, many ceased to
plead with the guilty inhabitants of
Sodom.
And all but Lot
with his wife and two daughters were
consumed by the fire sent down from
heaven.
So in the days of Christ, the Son of God
declares to the unbelieving Jews of that
generation, "Your house is left unto you
desolate,
looking down to the last days,
when the uh the same infinite power
declares concerning those who receive
not the love of the truth that they
might be saved. For this cause God shall
send them strong delusion that they
should believe a lie that they might be
damned who believe not the truth but had
pleasure in unrighteousness. Quoting 2
Thessalonians 2:10-12.
As they reject the teachings of his
word, God withdraws his spirit and
leaves them to the deceptions which they
love. Close quote.
So, it's just assumed that this teaching
is biblical. It's light from heaven. No
questions asked. Even though it's a
theological novel of the 19th century.
Not just that, but if you reject this
doctrine, 2 Thessalonians 2:10-12
applies to you because you've rejected
the supposed teachings of scripture and
God will withdraw his spirit from you
and leave you in a deception.
One can't have impunity if they reject
this teaching after hearing it.
It's just a fact. This is what scripture
teaches despite all the holes and
blunders in the teaching, which is even
tacitly admitted by the SDA church,
seeing as the current iteration of the
teaching isn't the same as it was in the
19th century.
And if you don't believe the teaching,
you can't be benefited by Christ
mediation.
At the beginning of the book, page 17,
notice what she also says. Quote, "In
the future, deception of every kind is
to arise, and we want solid ground for
our feet. We want solid pillars for the
building. No one pin is to be removed
from that which the Lord has
established. The enemy will bring in
false theories such as the doctrine that
there is no sanctuary."
This is one of the points on which there
will be a departing from the faith.
Where shall we find safety unless it be
in the truths that the Lord has been
giving for the last 50 years? Close
quote.
So again, Adventists who want to say,
"I'm an Adventist and I reject the
investigative judgment because, you
know, it's a total coverup job that
can't be supported from biblical
exesus." Here you go. You've departed
from the Adventist faith despite your
profession of being one. And Uncle Ted
is telling leaders in the movement, "If
you aren't on board with this, resign."
90% of Adventists can't even properly
articulate this teaching.
Yet, salvation supposedly hinges on
understanding it.
This is why SDAs are so confused on the
gospel.
It's crazy. He said the sanctuary system
lays out the plan of salvation.
Yet this whole concept came about in the
19th century.
So everyone prior to that was saved in
ignorance of this supposed soulsaving
truth. But then arbitrarily in the 19th
century, everyone in the world is now
expected to listen to a band of
anti-trinitarian
gospel twisting fringe fanatics led by a
false prophet in the 19th century or
else we're damned.
They openly state in their own
publications, "This teaching was not
preached by the apostles, the church
fathers, the medieval fathers, etc."
Look folks, we've looked at this before.
JL Scheler, Review and Herald, May 5,
1932. Quote, "This prophecy of
Revelation 14 6-14, which the
investigative judgment is supposedly a
part of, does not and cannot refer to
any proclamation of the gospel in the
days of the apostles,
the early church fathers or Christian
fathers or the reformers of the 16th,
17th or 18th centuries. It is strictly a
last day message applicable to those who
live just before the return of Christ.
So, the sanctuary message, which Ted
says lays out the complete plan of
salvation,
wasn't preached by the apostles.
So, the apostles didn't have the
complete plan of salvation. No one did
until they came along.
Total insanity.
But they utilize the historical
grammatical method of interpretation.
Right?
Remember that's the only approved
hermeneutic of the SDA church.
And the and the HGM involves
understanding the author's intended
meaning and how the original audience
would have understood the text first
before arriving at present day
application.
We also got a lot of Christianes in
there, but of course they mean something
totally different.
Ted, the reason you guys are called
legalists
is because you are definitionally.
Adventists love to say that if you call
them legalists, you're disparaging
obedience. Again, utilizing the false
dilemma, the the false uh dilemma
fallacy.
By righteousness of Jesus Christ, they
mean that Jesus can gradually impart to
you bit by bit his righteousness in
cooperation with the heavenly trio which
will enable you to eventually arrive at
a sinlessly perfect state.
Even though Ted said earlier, "We're all
sinners at the foot of the cross." Yeah,
that's not what your pioneers taught,
buddy.
Yet, I have yet to meet the Adventist
that has actually arrived at this. it's
always just around the corner
or they have such a low bar not
realizing what that that Jesus himself
is the standard
that they've actually diluted themselves
into thinking they have no sin in their
life
meaning in thought word deed and motive
but look what she says here folks again
the inspired pen mind character and
personality page 564
he talking about Jesus came to
demonstrate the fact that humanity
allied by living faith to divinity can
keep all the commandments of God.
He came to make plain the immutable
character of the law to declare that
obedience and transgression can never be
rewarded with eternal life.
He came as a man to humanity that
humanity might touch humanity while
divinity laid hold upon the throne of
God.
I haven't met a single Adventist that
has living faith according to this
definition. Then not a single one that
was keeping the commandments perfectly.
Not even in letter.
Forget the the spirit of the law. Not
even in letter. We'd start to get into
specifics like when you're at work, do
you ever rob your employer of your time
on the clock in any way, shape, or form?
Is every single second of your time on
the clock given to your employer fully
or are you robbing them of any time?
Then all of a sudden they get skittish
because in their minds they're thinking,
"Well, I haven't gone to the store today
and stolen anything." As if the standard
ends there.
Furthermore, notice she claims salvation
is a reward. No, it isn't.
It's a gift.
A reward is something one receives for
recognition of their effort or
achievement.
So in this case, obedience is rewarded
with eternal life. When no, obedience is
the fruit of already having eternal life
given by God who is gracious enough to
bestow it on you and all the benefits
that come with being united to Christ,
which includes being born again, a new
creature in Christ, which results in a
changed life. But none of that is then
rewarded with eternal life. It's the
result of having eternal life already
given to you like Jesus and John taught.
John 5, 1 John 5.
Again, same thing. Sign of signs of the
times, July 31st, 1901. This isn't
toward the beginning of her life.
Adventists, they love to appeal to that.
Oh, that was early on in her life. Well,
she never made that caveat for one, but
two, this isn't toward the beginning of
her life. This is toward the end, 14
years before she died. quote, "For the
highest good of his creatures, God has
given a perfect law, a law that demands
perfect obedience."
God compels no one to obey this law. He
leaves men free to decide whether they
will obey and receive the reward of
obedience or disobey and receive the
punishment of transgression.
So obedience isn't just the fruit of
having already been reconciled to God,
born again, changed, etc. Nope. It's
what aids you along in the process of
salvation to eventually lead to being
rewarded with eternal life based on your
obedience.
Salvation is not rewarded on obedience.
Adventists,
salvation is a gift that God freely
bestows and gives
based on Jesus and him alone.
That's the whole purpose of grace.
It's undeserved. It's unmmerited favor.
Now, notice what she says. Now, we're
moving into the thus sayeth the Lord
territory. Great controversy, the 1888
edition, page 488. Quote, "Those who
would share the benefits of the Savior's
mediation should permit nothing to
interfere with their duty to perfect
holiness in the fear of God." I'm going
to pause here. Adventists love to say,
"No, no, no. She just taught was she
never taught anywhere that it's perfect
sinlessness just trying your best.
Is that what she says here?
If you want to share in Jesus's
mediation,
nothing can permit or interfere with the
duty to perfect holiness.
She continues, "The precious hours
instead of being given to pleasure, to
display, or to gain seeking should be
devoted to an earnest prayerful study of
the word of truth. The subject of the
sanctuary and the investigative judgment
should be clearly understood by the
people of God.
All need a knowledge for themselves of
the position and work of their great
high priest. Otherwise, it will be
impossible for them to exercise the
faith which is essential at this time or
to occupy the position which God designs
them to fill.
Every individual has a soul to save or
to lose. Each has a case pending at the
bar of God. Each must meet the great
judge face to face. Close quote.
So unless one demonstrates perfect
holiness, there it is. Adventists
And this is only one instance. If you
let anything interfere with perfect
holiness, Christ's mediation for you
will not happen.
Not just that, but you have to
understand the subject of the sanctuary
and investigative judgment clearly.
Otherwise, it will be impossible for you
to exercise the faith necessary to make
it through this process and fill the
position that God designed for you to
fill. Because each person has a case
pending at the bar of God.
And again, they'll utilize the false
dilemma fallacy and say, "So, you don't
think there's a coming judgment? Read
the Apostles Creed, friend.
Stop with the false dilemma fallacy that
if we disagree with this horrendous
theology, it therefore automatically
means this up other thing over here. You
need to study ancient historic
Christianity."
But Ted says there's confusion within
the movement over this doctrine. Yeah,
no kidding. Because the average SDA
isn't studying systematic theology, let
alone this system, which is a total
nightmare to navigate because of all the
patchwork over the two centuries of it
floundering.
Again, great controversy. Page 623.
Quote, "Now, while our great high priest
is making the atonement for us, we
should seek to become perfect in Christ.
Not that Christ is perfect already and
you're hidden in him, seen as holy,
blameless, etc. All the stuff that comes
with being united to him. No, no, no.
You need to seek to become perfect in
him. Meaning, have this righteousness
gradually imparted you over time to
where you get to a point, as you're
going to see in one of these future
quotes, or rather later on in this
quote, sorry.
We should seek to become perfect in
Christ. Not even a thought could our
savior be brought to yield to the power
of temptation. Remember that Adventists
Christ there was not even a single
thought. It's not just behavior. Not
even a thought
brought to yield to the power of
temptation. Satan finds in human hearts
some point where he can gain a foothold.
Some sinful desire is cherished by means
of which his temptations assert their
power. But Christ declared of himself,
"The prince of this world cometh and
hath nothing in me." John 14:30. Satan
could find nothing in the son of God
that would enable him to gain the
victory. Here's why I was pointing out
that line earlier. Not even a single
thought. He had kept his father's
commandments and there was no sin in him
that Satan could use to his advantage.
This is the condition in which those who
must be found who shall stand in the
time of trouble.
This is the condition in which those
must be found who shall stand in the
time of trouble.
Adventists, are you as perfect as Jesus
was?
Time of trouble is just around the
corner. Remember, James White said they
were about to enter it. It was present
truth for that time.
So, the atonement is still going on in
this long drawn out process supposedly.
And I have to supposedly believe that
even though scripture tells us that
Jesus functioned as a high priest when
he made propitiation, Hebrews 2, which
was at Calvary,
he was both the high priest offering up
the sacrificed which was also himself.
His body also being the temple. John 2.
Even though scripture tells us plainly
that atonement cannot be made without
the shedding of blood and Jesus isn't
shedding blood in heaven.
We have to believe all of this twisting
if we want to be saved because this is
part of this everlasting gospel that
they're taking to the dying world.
But also get that adventist. Like I
said, if you aren't at the level that
Jesus was at, the great example, you're
not going to make it through the time of
trouble that's been around the the
corner for 170 years.
As perfect as Jesus kept the
commandments,
so you too have to in order to make it
not try your best, not put forth your
best effort like a lot of SDAs want to
claim. No, the condition Jesus was in.
That's how you'll have to be found. So
get busy,
Ted. This is why you guys are called
legalistic. And I could keep going.
You guys use Christian language like
righteousness by faith and the
righteousness of Christ as if that
somehow waxes over the fact of what
you're actually saying
or waxes over the fact that you have a
false gospel.
which is a doctrinal mess because of the
sanctuary.
Here's what the Adventist church means
by righteousness by faith. Folks, Ellen
White, Faith and Works, page 118. Quote,
"It was impossible for the sinner to
keep the law of God, which was holy,
just, and good. But this impossibility
was removed by the impartation of the
righteousness of Christ to the repenting
believing soul."
The life and death of Christ in behalf
of sinful man were for the purpose of
restoring the sinner to God's favor
through impartation to him the
righteousness that would meet the claims
of the law and find acceptance with
Christ or or sorry with the father.
The life and death of Christ in behalf
of sinful man were for the purpose of
restoring the sinner to God's favor
through imparting to him the
righteousness that would meet the claims
of the law and find acceptance with the
father.
So they mean the gradual impartation of
Christ's righteousness which supposedly
empowers you to keep the law perfectly.
So Mr. and Mrs. Adventist, are you
keeping the law perfectly?
It is a myth that Christians are against
obedience like this movement likes to
claim. No, we are against your
butchering of the Bible and the
misplacing and misapplication of the
role of obedience and the role that it
plays.
Obedience flows from an individual that
God has regenerated already who is
attached and united to Jesus Christ by
faith.
But furthermore, in this atoning work
that Jesus is supposedly doing, people's
sins are still standing against them.
Despite one of the clear
promises of the new covenant being that
God doesn't remember a person's sins
anymore, Jeremiah 31, which is then
quoted in Hebrews 8:12.
Ted, you guys said you believe the plain
reading of the text.
Yet, when it comes to this, we're
supposed to suppress that, I guess.
Notice what their inspired pen says
regarding the supposed work of atonement
that Jesus is still doing. Christ in his
sanctuary, page 177. Quote,
"All who have truly repented of sin and
by faith claimed the blood of Christ as
their atoning sacrifice,
have had pardon entered against their
names in the books of heaven.
As they have become the partake as they
have become partakers of the
righteousness of Christ and their
characters are found to be in harmony
with the law of God, their sins will be
blotted out and they themselves will be
accounted worthy of eternal life.
So Ted said they should be champions of
righteousness of Christ in the world
which as we saw means that a person is
gradually imparted with Christ's merits
little by little based on their
cooperation.
In doing so they will eventually get to
a point where like in the last quote
they supposedly identically identically
mirror Jesus's character and
personality.
And it's at that point that a person's
character is in harmony with the law of
God. And at that point, their sins will
be blotted out and they'll be accounted
worthy of eternal life.
Completely contradicting that God
remembers believers sins no more when
they're washed by the renewal of
regeneration, united to Christ, seen as
holy and blameless by virtue of being
hidden in Christ Jesus. Colossians 3:3.
Yes, sir. You guys are legalists to a
tea.
You can hide behind words like obedience
and whatever else, but for anyone that
can see through the smoke and mirrors,
you are legalists.
You think Christ's righteousness is not
something imputed in full to a person
such that such that they are then hidden
in Christ, but that a Levitical
priesthood Adventist Jesus gradually
imparts his merits to a person bit by
bit in their efforts to obey. And it's
that dual action that results in then
being eventually seen as righteous.
Your sins eventually being blotted out
and then you're rewarded and seen as
worthy of salvation
despite again the plain reading of
scripture where Jesus taught that people
can know that they have present tense
eternal life already. John 5 and John
teaching the same thing in his his
epistle 1 John 5:13.
You guys only want to roll with this
plain reading of the text when it's
convenient.
And all of that, which we didn't even
come close to covering at all, is the
core of your guys' novel gospel message
that the apostles weren't even teaching.
You have a false gospel. Period. But
also, Ted, you ignored this problematic
aspect of your prophetus. He claimed
that the work of the first apartment was
finished at Calvary.
Did you hear that? He said the work of
the first apartment was finished at
Calvary. What's taking place in heaven
is completely identical to what was on
earth, just only up in heaven. Oh,
really?
Then why does Ellen White claim that the
work of the first apartment took place
up until 1844 when Jesus got up and
moved into the second apartment?
Great controversy. Page 428.
quote,
"In the service of the earthly
sanctuary, which as we have seen is a
figure of the service in the heavenly,
when the high priest on the day of
atonement entered the most holy place,
the ministration in the first apartment
ceased."
When did it cease? Not at Calvary.
God commanded,
"There shall be no man in the tabernacle
of the congregation when he goeth in to
make an atonement in the holy place
until he comes out."
So when Christ entered the Holy of
Holies to perform the closing work of
the atonement, he ceased his
ministration in the first apartment.
But when the ministration in the first
apartment ended, the ministration in the
second apartment began.
When in the typical service the high
priest left the holy on the day of
atonement, he went in before God to
present the blood of the sin offering in
behalf of all of Israel who truly
repented of their sins. So Christ had
only completed one part of his work as
our intercessor to enter upon another
portion of the work and he still pleaded
his blood before the father in behalf of
sinners. Close quote.
prior to 1844.
He claims that Jesus was only doing a
work analogous to that of the Levitical
priests in a physical building in heaven
in a first apartment work
of which you mentioned Ted as being
identical to what was on earth.
Yet again, using the plain reading of
the Bible that you implored people to
utilize, scripture plainly says he
entered into God's presence at his
ascension. Hebrews 9:24, God's presence
was only ever contained in the most
holy, not the holy place.
You said it was identical. This is why
you guys try and prove too much and end
up shooting yourself in the foot.
This is one of those areas that you guys
have pivoted on because of the flack you
received regarding your pioneers saying
insane stuff like no atonement took
place at the cross and no sins were
canceled at the cross.
of which your prophet has claimed in the
infamous patriarchs and prophets quote.
But quotes like this, folks, we've
looked at these before. Uriah Smith,
Advent, Ad Advent Review and Sabbath
Herald, October 19, 1876. Quote, "The
death of Christ and the atonement are
not the same thing."
And this relieves matter of all
difficulty.
Christ did not make atonement when he
shed his blood upon the cross. Let this
fact be fixed forever in the mind.
Ted, show me where the Adventist Church
has denounced this heresy. Or do you
not?
You claimed that Jesus accomplished the
work of the first apartment on the
cross. Well, the entire chain of work
that the priest performed entailed
atonement being made. It all involved
blood, both first and second apartment.
Yet your church's pioneer theologian and
anti-trinitarian heretic Uriah Smith
says Christ didn't make atonement on the
cross and we're to let that fact be
fixed in our minds forever. Again,
Whittle Little John, another one of your
pioneers. Advent Review, September 16,
1884.
Quote, I believe that there is not a
single passage among those usually
employed to prove that the atonement
took place at the cross that will
justify such a con uh such a conclusion.
The doctrine itself is contrary to
reason.
When sin is once atoned for, it is fully
disposed of and can never be charged to
the account of the offender again. To
reason, therefore, that the sins of
those who are converted were atoned for
on the cross would be to argue that such
persons could not be lost.
Close quote. Total heresy.
It's contrary to reason. He says, "No,
it's contrary to your guys's false
system and worldview, so you reject it
in favor of upholding your great
controversy paradigm." He rightly
recognizes that, yeah, when sin's atoned
for, it can't be held against them,
which is exactly what scripture teaches.
So, Ted, maybe you need to be warning
people about reading your own pioneers
then
that or you need to warn people about
listening to you because those quotes
from your prophetists and pioneers
contradict what you just claimed. But
more importantly, all of you contradict
the Bible.
when we just do like you told us and
believe the Bible as it reads. And no,
Christ didn't enter a real second
apartment of a building in heaven. You
guys love to site Hebrews 8 1-2 thinking
that supports this theory. Yet, the
author expounds upon this if you don't
do the hopscotch exesus and just read
through to the next chapter. It says
Jesus entered into heaven itself. Heaven
itself is the most holy place where
God's presence permeates. It's not
contained to an apartment in a building.
You're you're trying to prove too much
through type and shadow.
Jesus doesn't have to be doing
everything that you guys claim to be
functioning as a high priest either.
Notice there's no mention of of Christ's
kingly work.
You guys love to claim that Christians
have forgotten about the priestly work
of Christ when they reject this horrible
doctrine.
Yet you guys have nothing in your
fundamental beliefs on this one.
Fundamental belief number 24 about the
kingly work of Christ which is what
actually began at his ascension.
Not his priestly work like the
fundamental belief for the investigative
judgment says. Jesus continued as a high
priest and was inaugurated as a king at
his ascension.
He's after the order of MelkiseDC, not
Levi. And MelkiseDC was both a priest
and a king. And Jesus mediates from a
throne,
not standing dealing with sin still, but
as a reigning king of kings and lord of
lords while all of his enemies are being
made a foottool. He's not dealing with
sin and working with blood up in heaven.
But then he said, "You're not saved by
being vegan," meaning adhering to the
health message. Ted, when you guys say
this, I noticed the reluctancy, too,
when you said it.
It's damage control and cope.
How do I know this? Councils on diet and
foods. Page 63.
Quote, "Meat should not be placed before
our children. Its influence is to excite
and strengthen the lower passions and
has a tendency to deaden the moral
powers. Grains and fruits prepared free
from grease and in as natural a
condition as possible should be the food
for the tables of all who claim to be
preparing for translation to heaven.
Your guy's big thing is supposedly
warning the world of the impending doom
to come and that we have but a little
time to be be prepared for Jesus's soon
return. This call is to get people
prepared to be ready when Jesus returns.
Part of that entails this health
message.
Here your prophetist states that grains
and fruits free from grease should be
the food one eats who claim to be
preparing for that.
Which means if you're eating meat, you
aren't going to be ready for when Jesus
returns and won't be translated. Again,
same book.
Vegetables, fruits, and grains should
compose our diet. Not an ounce of flesh
meat should enter our stomachs. The
eating of flesh is unnatural. We are to
return to God's original purpose in the
creation of man. Councils in d on diet
and foods. Page 380. Again, same page,
same book. Among those who are waiting
for the coming of the Lord,
meat eating will eventually be done
away. Flesh will cease to form a part of
their diet. Close quote.
If you don't abstain from meat eating,
you won't be prepared for Jesus's return
and won't be translated. Only those who
are truly waiting for his return will
cease to eat meat. And she claimed that
going against her writings was to go
against the spirit of God and will be
treated by God as such, which would mean
it's a sin because it's supposedly going
against God, which means you wouldn't
have the perfect character and obedience
needed that she mentioned earlier.
Again, same book, page 70,
the Apostle Paul exhorts the church. I
beseech you therefore, brethren, by the
mercies of God, that ye present your
bodies a living sacrifice, wholly,
acceptable unto God, which is your
reasonable service. Men then can make
their bodies unholy by sinful
indulgences. If unholy, they are
unfitted to be spiritual worshippers and
are not worthy of heaven.
If man will cherish the light that God
in mercy gives him upon health reform
that includes veganism and
vegetarianism,
he may be sanctified through the truth
and fitted for immortality.
But if he disregards that light and
lives in violation of natural law, he
must pay the penalty. Close quote. You
guys don't teach your message on health
reform is a salvation issue, sir. Yeah,
right.
If one doesn't adhere to it, they won't
be fitted for heaven.
This is because you guys claim that
heaven will essentially be a return to
Eden and people will be on the identic
diet in heaven. So, now's the time to
demonstrate you'll essentially be okay
with that and be able to adhere to the
heavenly diet.
It's a part of your probation.
And again, perfect holiness is the
standard which she said earlier. If you
don't adhere to your guys' health reform
message, she says here, "You are unfit
for heaven and won't be fitted for
immortality because you're unholy."
And just to top it all off,
God gave the light on health reform and
those that reject it reject God.
The 1903 General Conference bulletin
posted multiple places.
So, if you reject this message and say,
"Nah, I tried the vegetarian lifestyle.
Didn't work for my body type." But more
power to those that want to. We've
rejected God because this message is
supposedly from him.
So, don't try and twist your guys'
system
and downplay it. You love to site Ellen
White. So, let's not do the selective
citation, which I know Adventists love
to do. They love to focus on all the
flowery uplifting quotes and ignore all
the total blunders. But then notice he
mentioned something I referenced in a
video a couple weeks ago and Adventists
were coming for my throat. You don't
know what you're talking about. You're
confused.
That in the future Jesus is going to
take off his priestly robes and put on
his kingly robes.
And this is why there's very little
mention of Jesus functioning as a king
right now. Of course, they pay lip
service to saying Jesus is on the
throne, but this is just more crossing
wires and double speak.
No concept of Jesus's kingly role
presently in this movement.
They try and fault Christians for saying
they don't understand Jesus's priestly
role. Yet, they have no concept of Jesus
as a king.
You can't be a king when you don't have
a kingdom yet. Kings rule over kingdoms.
And in in the Adventist system, Jesus
hasn't received his kingdom his kingdom
yet. That happens after the
investigative judgment closes.
What Ted mentions corresponds with
exactly what Ellen White claimed
regarding Jesus ceasing his function as
a priest
where he will then cease being a priest
and mediating for people and assume the
true role and reign as king at that
point. First, notice what she says
again. Christ in his sanctuary, page
153.
quote,
"Those who are living upon the earth
when the intercession of Christ shall
cease in the heavenly sanctu in the
sanctuary above are to stand in the
sight of a holy God without a mediator.
Their robes must be spotless." Not
trying your best, Adventists. Spotless.
Their characters must be purified from
sin by the blood of sprinkling through
the grace of God and their own diligent
effort. They must be conquerors in the
battle with evil. While the
investigative judgment is going forward
in heaven, while the sins of penitent
believers are being removed from the
sanctuary, there is to be a special work
of purification of putting away of sin
among God's people upon earth. This work
is more closely presented in the
messages of Revelation 14. Close quote.
So very clearly she claims Jesus will
cease functioning as a priest in his
role as a mediator and one will have to
stand before God Almighty without an
intercessor.
You'll have to be a conqueror in the
battle of evil without one.
Then in thoughts from the mount of
blessing, page 107,
quote, "The kingdom of God's grace is
now being established as day by day
hearts that have been full of sin and
rebellion yield to the sovereignty of
his love. But the full establishment of
the kingdom of his glory will not take
place until the second coming of Christ
to this world." That's what that's what
Ted was just talking about,
the removal. This is from early writings
where she talks about the removal of the
priestly garment to the kingly garment.
You have scholars like Roy Ga and others
in the SDA church saying that that's
representative of function. He's not
literally wearing Levitical priesthood
garments when people bring the charge
that why' she see him wearing Levitical
priesthood garments when he's after the
order of Mkisedc. Oh no, it's just
visual for her to see him functioning as
a priest. Oh, so when he switches
garments to the kingly garments, that's
when he'll begin the work as a king.
Well, here we have the full
establishment of the kingdom of his
glory will not take place until the
second coming of Christ to this world.
That's what Ted was just referencing.
The kingdom and dominion and the
greatest of the kingdom under the whole
heaven is to be given to the people of
the saints of the most high. Daniel
7:27. They shall inherit the kingdom
prepared for them from the foundation of
the world. And Christ will take to
himself his great power and will reign.
When will he take it? When will he
reign? When will that kingdom fully
come?
At the second coming, Jesus will switch
from priestly garments. Again, folks, we
just did a video on this. You can go
check it out. It's the last video in the
Adventist Jesus series. You can see the
quote yourself from early writings.
He will switch from his priestly
garments, meaning his function as a
priest, and put on his kingly garments,
his rule and reign over the kingdom.
This is totally misplaced.
Jesus is already ruling and reigning as
a priest, king, simultaneous role.
And as the author of Hebrews explicitly
tells us, Ted again using your own
standard of the plain reading of the
Bible, he forever lives to make
intercession for his people. As we're
going to see momentarily,
what he is doing now, he will forever
do.
The author tells us that unlike the
Levites, Jesus's priesthood goes on
forever because unlike them, he cannot
and will not die. Get your Bible out,
folks. Hebrews 7
starting Hebrews 7 1-4. Buckle up. I
told you this was going to be a long
section. It's going to be a long night.
This is important. It's not all
spiritual milk all the time, folks. It's
not just a couple verses here and there
like like these people do. We're talking
about meat. We're not on spiritual milk
all the time. It's time to get to where
you can eat meat if you're an Adventist.
We're going verse by verse by verse.
We're not doing this hopscotching
around.
Ted said the only approved hermeneutic
is the HGM. Okay. Well, that's what
we're utilizing here. How would the
original audience have understood this?
What did the author intend to
communicate? To get that, you got to go
through verse by verse, not hopping all
over the Bible just citing stuff.
Hebrews 7 1-4. This is right after the
author says at the end of Hebrews 6 that
Jesus entered behind the veil which at
which Ellen White tried to claim well
that's the veil between the courtyard
and the first apartment. No, it's not
because he says he entered behind the
veil after the order of MelkiseDC.
MelkiseDC was a high priest which is in
reference to the veil that only the high
priest could go behind which is the veil
to the most holy place because Jesus
entered into the presence of God which
was in the most holy place which is
heaven itself. Hebrews 7 1-4.
For this MelkiseDC, king of Salem,
priest of the most high God,
met Abraham, returning from the
slaughter of the kings, and blessed him.
And to him Abraham appointed a tenth of
a tenth part of everything, a tithe. He
is first by by translation of his name
king of righteousness, and then he is
also king of Salem, that is king of
peace.
He is without father or mother or
genealogy, having neither beginning of
days nor end of life. But resembling the
son of God, he continues a priest
forever.
Mkisedc was both a priest and a king. A
priest king simultaneously.
Mkisedc was a type and shadow of Christ,
which is what that last phrase there is
getting at.
This then sets the stage for the entire
point of this chapter, which is that
Jesus is better than this type figure,
which is the whole point of the whole
book of Hebrews, which we're going to
get into a bunch more later. First, he
explains that Abraham gave ties to
Melkisedc and Levi was in the loins of
Abraham, which was a demonstration of
Melkisedc being superior to the Levites.
That's why he's mentioning this. But
then, let's read 11-28 because that's he
goes on to talk about the tithe in those
in between verses between 4 and 11.
But pay close attention. Now, if
perfection had been attainable through
the Levitical priesthood, for under it
the people received the law, what
further need would there have been for
another priest to arise after the order
of Mkisedc
rather than one named after the order of
Aaron.
For when there is a change in the
priesthood, there is necessarily a
change in the law as well. For the one
of whom those things are spoken belonged
to another tribe from which no one was
ever has ever served at the altar. For
it is evident that our Lord was
descended from Judah and in connection
with the that tribe Moses said nothing
about priests.
This becomes even more evident when
another priest arises in the likeness of
MelkiseDC who has become a priest not on
the basis of legal requirement
concerning uh bodily descent but by the
power of an indestructible life
for it is witnessed of him now quoting
from the Psalms you were a priest
forever after the order of MelkiseDC.
You were a priest for how long?
forever.
For on the one hand, a former
commandment in uh
sorry, for on the one hand, a former
commandment I just had a thought there.
It's interesting that SDAs don't use the
word association fallacy here to talk
about uh inserting ten commandments into
here. The word commandment, a former
commandment is set aside because of its
weakness and uselessness.
Is that the ten commandments,
Adventists? They're set aside and
useless.
For the law made nothing perfect. But on
the other hand, a better hope is
introduced through which we draw near to
God. And it was not without an oath. For
those who formally became priests were
such without an oath. But this one was
made a priest with an oath by the one
who said to him, again quoting from the
psalmist, "The Lord has sworn and will
not change his mind. Again, you are a
priest forever.
This makes Jesus a guarantor of a better
covenant.
The former priests were many in number
because they were prevented by death
from continuing in office. But he,
talking about Jesus, holds his
priesthood permanently
because he continues forever.
Consequently, he's able to save to the
uttermost those who draw near to God
through him.
since he always lives to make
intercession for them.
I'm letting this soak Adventist. It's
right there. He's a priest forever. He
always lives to make intercession. He'll
rule and reign forever. The function
he's doing now will be forever.
Please believe the word of God.
For it was indeed fitting that we should
have such a high priest, holy, innocent,
unstained, separated from sinners, and
exalted above the heavens. He has no
need, like those high priests, to offer
sacrifices daily. That's the daily
ministration work. First for his own
sins and then for those of the people
since he did this once for all when he
offered up himself. He wasn't doing a
daily ministration work until 1844.
For the law appoints men in their
weakness as high priests, but the word
of the oath, which came later than the
law, appoints a son who has been made
perfect forever.
Wow.
Jesus is a priest forever by virtue of
the oath spoken over him by God the
Father. Quoting from the psalter, it was
foretold that Jesus would be a priest
forever.
This is because he's prevented from
death by virtue of his life continuing
forever. Unlike the Levitical priests,
because of this, he forever lives to
make intercession for his people. He's
not ceasing at a point in the future,
putting on different garments, and then
assuming a different role. It's a
simultaneous role like Mkisedc had.
And unlike the Levitical priests, Jesus
is able to save to the uttermost, not
try his best in some controversy with
one of his creatures. No, he's a perfect
savior. He actually saves and then
forever lives to mediate for those
people and keep them.
Ted, utilizing the standard of believing
the Bible as it reads might be one of
the best pieces of advice you've ever
given. And I hope Adventists will heed
that advice and start doing so by
reading the Bible verse by verse, seeing
what the author intended to communicate
contextually and then deriving the
application from that instead of
hopscotching all over the place.
Number five, misconceptions about
biblical creation. The 7th Day Adventist
Church believes that God created this
earth recently in six literal days like
our current days. Personally, I'll just
tell you this. I fully believe in a
short chronology accepting the biblical
history and spirit of prophecy
indication that this very earth is only
about 6,000 years old.
The seventh day adventist
Sabbath or the seventh day Sabbath is
the memorial of the creation of that
incredible event of creation and it
gives complete meaning to our keeping of
the seventh day Sabbath today. The
Sabbath points to our creator and
redeemer and is a powerful part of each
of the three angels messages of
Revelation 14 6-12.
All right, going to be a decent pit stop
again here, folks. I told you earlier we
are going to get into this. Get your
Bible, esword, whatever it may be. Go to
Hebrews 3 and 4. Should already be in
Hebrews because we were just there. Ted
and the SDA church recognize the
incredible event of creation and say
that the Sabbath is a memorial of
creation. Ted, I could not agree more.
This platform's public stated position
agrees with you, sir. There's only one
major caveat.
And unfortunately for you guys, it's the
central hinge of the topic and that is
new creation.
Something you guys never mention in the
discussion.
You guys seem to have this idea that the
new creation is some pie in the sky
future state that hasn't begun or
started yet. When no, the new creation
has already started, sir. Which
evidences we're already in it. It just
hasn't reached its total completion yet.
The curse still has to be lifted. The
resurrection and glorification of the
body has to happen, etc. But you
yourself cited 2 Corinthians 5:17
earlier, sir. And I don't think you
actually grasp the depth and breadth of
what what Paul is getting at in that
chapter.
Same as as when he says in Ephesians 2
that believers are the workmanship of
Christ. This isn't just some like, oh,
he's using like poetic language. No.
there's something a lot deeper going on.
I agree the Sabbath is a memorial of
creation.
But in order to have a cogent discussion
on the Sabbath, we have to discuss both
old and new creation, not just the old.
You guys are stuck in the old creation.
As I mentioned earlier, you're always
looking backward.
Which is why it's ironic that you ex
exhorted Adventists to keep their eyes
forward. But Christ brought about a new
creation which was the redemption of the
old creation that fell. And Jesus Christ
paralleled the work of creation in the
renewing of it into a new creation.
Which is why now we're going to walk
through like I've done before
through Hebrews 4 1-11. So I'm going to
read it all, then we're going to break
it down. Okay, folks.
Hebrews 4 1-11.
Quote,
"Therefore, while the promise of
entering his rest still stands, let us
uh let us fear lest any of you should
seem to have uh failed to reach it. For
good news came to us just as just as to
them, but the message they heard did not
benefit them, because they were not
united by faith with those who listened.
For we who have believed enter that rest
as he said, as I swore my wrath, they
shall not enter my rest."
although his works were finished from
the foundation of the world.
For he has somewhere spoken of the
seventh day in this way. And God rested
on the seventh day from all his works.
And again in this passage he said, "They
shall not enter my rest."
Since therefore it remains for some to
enter it, and those who formally
received the good news failed to enter
because of disobedience, again he
appoints a certain day, today, saying
through David so long afterward, in the
words already quoted, "Today, if you
hear his voice, do not harden your
hearts."
For if Joshua had given them rest, God
would not have spoken of another day
later on. So then there remains a
Sabbath rest for the people of God. For
whoever has entered God's rest has also
rested from his works as God did from
his. Let us therefore strive to enter
that rest so that no one may fail by the
same sort of disobedience.
So we have an article on our website
that breaks this down more fully. But
notice
if you look at the last words of Hebrews
chapter 3, he quoted Psalm 95:11.
in Hebrews 3:11 saying, "I swore in my
wrath, they shall not enter my rest."
Then he said in verse 19, 3:19, "They
were unable to enter," which begs the
question, "Enter what?"
The rest.
And why was that? Because of unbelief,
which keys us in on the vehicle by which
this rest that is in focus can be
entered.
So the picture in view is the children
of Israel in the wilderness,
redeemed by God through divine
providence out of the land of Egypt.
They're brought across the Red Sea,
brought through the wilderness through
mighty miracles, ready to enter the
promised land. But then multitudes of
them die in the wilderness because they
didn't enter the rest.
With that on his mind,
the author then exhorts the reader that
he doesn't want them
or us in that case to fail to enter the
rest of God the way they failed to enter
that rest. He's using Israel as an
illustration, an example of what not to
do.
the original audience, the Hebrew
Christians, the converts would have
understood this history.
Then in verse two, let me actually go
back on this.
He gives a sharp warning,
which is that the gospel didn't benefit
those in the wilderness who didn't
believe. He says the good news came to
them. That's the gospel. the good news.
The gospel is not unique to only the New
Testament. When the Apostle Paul wants
to explain the gospel, what does he use
to support it? In Romans 4, for example,
Genesis 15:6,
where Abraham believed and the Lord
credited to him as righteousness. He
uses the Old Testament to preach
justification by grace.
Same gospel proclaimed since Genesis 3.
So, Israel had the pure gospel preached
to them by God himself, but they didn't
believe it. So, the rest that is in
focus is one that has to do with
believing God. And failure to believe
God will keep one from entering.
Which is why then in verses 4-7
or 3-7, he goes on to say, "It still
remains for some to enter that rest."
He will then tell us what this rest is
in a moment. But first, he wants us to
understand that this is not just
something for Israel back then somewhere
in the ancient past as if it doesn't
have anything to do with us today, which
the original audience could have been
tempted to think, well, that's about our
ancestors. That's about Joshua. That's
about Moses. That's about them. No, it's
about he's using that as an example for
us today.
Now, notice verses 6 and 7. He applies
Psalm 95:11 to us. He isn't simply
giving us a history lesson about the
children of Israel. He's gives us an
exhortation for today.
The wilderness is a picture of life and
bondage to sin.
Don't disobey in the wilderness of life
like they did and fail to believe the
gospel which is the better redemption,
the better exodus, freedom from slavery
to sin, not just slavery to to Babylon.
This is after the authors already
explained in chapter 3 how Jesus is a
better Moses and Joshua. Joshua led the
Israelites into the earthly promised
land which was a type and shadow of
Christ who led a better redemption into
a better promised land. And Moses was
the mediator who was a type and shadow
of Jesus who is a better mediator. So
that's the backstory thus far. Now,
in verses 8-10, he's going to begin to
explain to us what the rest is, but also
make a distinction that's important to
catch. A lot of people miss this.
He says, "If Joshua had given them rest,
God would not have spoken of another day
later on."
Joshua and the Israelites were observing
the 7th day Sabbath memorial.
He mentions it back in verse four and
contrasts it here. God wouldn't have
through the psalmist spoken of another
day if there wasn't one.
Lots of commentators associate another
day with the phrase today. That's been
mentioned throughout chapters 3 and 4.
And that is correct. Today is the day to
enter the rest of God by believing.
Today is the day of salvation. Today if
you hear his voice, don't harden your
hearts. And so on. But there's something
else going on. And I'm not just coming
up with this on my own, by the way. As
we're going to see in a moment, the rest
he is talking about is not the land of
Canaan, which the original audience
would have been tempted to think. They
had been tempted to think the children
of Israel didn't believe God in the
wilderness and died. Therefore, they
didn't enter the rest of the land of
Canaan,
which that is true. And he tells us that
the land of Canaan is a picture of the
ultimate rest, but it's not the ultimate
rest. Which he explains in the next
verse when he says, "If Joshua had given
them rest, God would not have spoken of
another day later on," showing that
Joshua didn't actually give them the
rest even though he took them into the
land of Canaan. So he's saying if Joshua
who brought the children of Israel into
the promised land 40 years later was
giving them the ultimate rest, God
wouldn't have through the psalmist
spoken of another one later on to come.
Again, the Hebrew believer that this was
written to would have been tempted to
hear this and think that was for our
ancestors back there somewhere. On what
grounds do you propose to us, whoever
the author is? Some say Paul. Let's say
Paul. On what grounds, Paul, do you
propose another rest?
They would have thought the next
generation under Joshua's leadership
went in and enjoyed the rest that the
previous generation with under Moses
failed to enter. So on what grounds do
you propose there's a different one to
which he then cites the psalmist.
Now notice what the Puritan the prince
of Puritans John Owen writes in his
commentary on Hebrews 4. An absolute
gold mine of an explanation. He's
explaining how the author anticipates
this objection from the Jewish convert
audience,
those Hebrew Christians who would have
been very familiar with the Old
Testament. Notice what he says. Quote,
the writer of the Hebrew, the writer to
the Hebrews provides two answers to this
objection. First, a denial of the
supposition on which the objection is
founded. This is done virtually in the
manner of the proposal of the objection
itself. For if Joshua had given them
rest, that is whatever he pretended and
pleaded, he did not do so. That is not
that full and ultimate rest which in all
things God aimed at. Secondly, he gives
the reason of the of this his denial
which is this that 500 years later God
in David and by him proposes another
rest or another day of rest and invites
the people unto an entrance after they
were so long fully possessed of all that
Joshua conducted them into. And whereas
there was no new rest for the people to
enter into the days of David. And the
psalm wherein these words are recorded
is acknowledged to be prophetical of the
days of the Messiah. It unavoidably
follows that there is yet a rest and a
day of rest remaining for the people of
God, which he lays down as his
conclusion in the verse following. Close
quote.
Folks, I highly recommend Owen's Hebrews
commentary.
He absolutely knocks it out of the park.
I know he's a little difficult to read,
but he brings out the language of the
text so well. Joshua nor Moses gave
God's people the true and ultimate rest.
Hence why God through David 500 years
later spoke of another rest. And Owen
rightly points out that there are two
rests in view here that the author
distinguishes between. There is the
eternal rest that we have in the gospel
by being in Christ as well as a day of
rest that remains which is what the
author then proceeds to explain.
This is what the historical grammatical
method of interpretation actually looks
like by the way folks. Not this
hopscotching around the Bible like Ted
did. But then in verse 9, let's go back
here.
Then in verse nine,
so there remains a Sabbath rest for the
people of God. The Greek word for
Sabbath here is sabatismas, which
includes more than just a rest. It
literally means a Sabbath rest or
Sabbathkeeping.
There remains a Sabbathkeeping for the
people of God. To this point, the author
has referred to the rest of God as
catapos. That's the word. But here he
now uses sabatismos.
Grammatically they are not identical. He
says that not only does a rest remain
catapos but a sabbath rest as well.
That's why Owen rightly recognized that
there are two rests in focus.
Not only is there a new rest of God that
was prophetically foretold, aka the
gospel rest for the soul by being in
Christ, but another day also.
There's an eternal rest we have yet to
enter. We have access to that by being
new creatures in Christ, by believing
the gospel. We're given the spirit as a
down payment, a seal um and of the
inheritance that we that we have. That's
the cataposus rest. The Sabbath rest
that remains, the Sabbatism is a a new
day that memorializes that which is
what's then uh uh going on here. It's a
new day that memorializes um that future
rest.
Now, Adventists love to cite verse four,
which talks about the seventh day in the
original creation, and then jump to here
to verse 9 to say because the Sabbath
rest remains, it must be the seventh day
Sabbath because it's mentioned in verse
four.
No, that cannot be the case because the
Sabatismos that remains is another day.
It isn't the catapus rest that's another
day, but the Sabatismos,
which means Adventists can huff and puff
all they want, but we know for certain
it isn't the seventh day. By definition,
it's another day in contrast to the
seventh.
Now, the previous rest of God in both
the original creation, Exodus 20:8, and
redemption from Egypt, Deuteronomy
5:12-15,
had three elements that parallel one
another.
Mighty acts of God working,
God completing that work, and then he
ceases or rests from that work and
switches to the work of upholding what
he's done, which is then where verse 10
becomes pivotal. pivotal.
He that has entered into his rest has
also ceased from his works as God did
from his. The milliondoll question
becomes, who is the he that is
mentioned?
Owen gets into this in his commentary.
A common interpretation is that this is
talking about believers in general
entering God's rest.
The issue with that interpretation
though, folks, I used to to say this as
well, lots of Christians do, but the
issue is is that the he in Greek is
singularly personal, meaning it's a it's
a specific individual in reference. It's
not a general reference to believers.
The NASB's translation actually is
spoton. It's a home run. Instead of he
it reads for the one who has entered his
rest has also himself
rested from his works as God did from
his. A single individual is being talked
about who entered his own rest just as
God rested from his works and entered
his rest.
It is a parallel to what God did in
creation which is why Hebrews 4:4
mentions the seventh day.
The he that entered his rest must be
doing so in a parallel way to God in
creation.
God finished his works saw that they
were very good. So he ceased and rested
the seventh day. If we apply this text
to believers, we have to ask what works
do believers cease from that parallel
God's ceasing at his at creation.
We can't compare our works to God's
works.
Meaning, we can't compare our attempts
at working for salvation and resting
from those to God's works. Our attempts
at working for salvation do not compare
to God's work in creation, which is a
which was a mighty, miraculous act. And
clearly, we don't take delight in and
enjoy our previous works as God did in
being pleased with his work of creation.
He was taking delight in his
accomplishment. He wasn't tired. We
don't rest from our works of sin and
then look over that previous work with
delight. So it's not a consistent
parallel to say that the he is sing
which is singularly personal in the
Greek is about us.
The he in verse 10 must be someone who
did a work comparable to God's work in
creation.
A mighty act of one work that was two
completed and followed by three a rest.
A work that is good and he can take
delight in that when those works were
finished he ceased from them just as God
in creation followed by entering his
rest
is talking about Jesus my friend.
It's talking about Jesus.
Jesus did a mighty work of redeeming the
creation, ushering in the new creation.
He completed that work successfully and
upon doing so entered into his
mediatorial rest for his people.
He paralleled God in the original
creation by following the same pattern
in the work of redeeming that creation
that fell, which brought about a better
redemption led by a better leader, a
better priest, a better mediator, a
better Sabbath, and a better promised
land.
The name Joshua means Jehovah saves.
Joshua was a type and shadow of Jesus
who led a better redemption and exodus
out of slavery to sin into a better
promised land. The true promised land
like Hebrews 12 talks us that Abraham
looked forward to the better promised
land, not physical Canaan. That was a
type,
our eternal rest, our eternally our
eternal heavenly abode.
Now, some will argue that the he in
verse 10 doesn't specify Christ, that he
wasn't referred to by name. We have to
remember that Hebrews 4 is a
continuation from chapter 3. And in
Hebrews 3:6-14, Christ is mentioned by
name. So, it's not necessary for the
author to mention him again when this
chapter is an outflowing of the same
focus and Jesus is the central focus.
The text fits fits much better when
applied to Christ rather than believers.
So then the only thing left to establish
is when Christ entered his rest after
his works of redemption were finished,
which was the first day when he walked
out of the tomb. Which is precisely why
I have said and will continue to point
out that when the SDAs b and scoff at
Christians who may not be as learned on
theology and who say we worship on the
first day because of the resurrection,
Adventists do not realize that is a
summation statement.
The resurrection was when the work of
redemption was accomplished and a new
creation was brought about. Jesus being
the first fruits of that new creation.
So God in creation entered his rest the
seventh day. But God in Christ entered
on the first or eighth day when that
mighty miraculous work of redemption was
completed.
The creation falling did not catch God
by surprise. Folks,
the plan of Jesus to redeem creation was
always the plan. And the original
creation itself was a type and shadow of
the new and better creation and a better
work of redemption.
I know that's not the case in the great
controversy worldview.
The plan of salvation had to be proposed
by Jesus as an afterthought and the
father had to be convinced of it. But
that's not coming from scripture. 1
Corinthians 15 1-4 clearly states that
the resurrection was a part of Christ's
work. Remember Paul said if Christ is
not raised from the dead, our faith is
useless.
Death on the cross as a sacrifice was
not enough if he wasn't raised.
The resurrection is the transition point
where Jesus went from his humiliation,
leaving his heavenly abode by adding
unto himself human flesh in the
incarnation to his exaltation, the
period from his resurrection through to
the second coming. He humiliated all the
way down from heaven to the heart of the
earth. But then that all reverses with
his resurrection where he resurrects and
is highly exalted as savior, king of
kings, and lord of lords. and he returns
back to his rightful status after
completing the work.
That's how Jesus can be the true
fulfillment of the Sabbath. Yet a
sabatismos, a Sabbath rest remains. But
it's another day, the day when Jesus
accomplished redemption and entered his
rest, the first day.
We enter into Christ by faith who's
already entered into God's rest ahead of
us, the true promised land that we look
forward to, our eternal rest with God.
Until then, a weekly Sabatismos remains
where we gather as the body of Christ to
have a little foretaste of that as we
gather alongside uh one another and
heaven, communion of the saints, to
worship and remember the mighty work
that King Jesus accomplished for his
people. We have rest for our souls in
the gospel and a weekly rest for our
bodies until we enter into the eternal
rest of heaven where our bodies are then
glorified and no longer need that.
So Adventists can huff and puff all they
want, but it does not change the text.
And I care about the grammar and what
the author intended,
as you guys are supposed to as well,
apparently since Ted told us the only
method of interpretation approved by the
SDA church is the historical grammatical
method.
Well, that's what we just utilized, my
friend. And the author plainly tells us
that the Sabbatismos that remains, you
guys love that verse, is another day.
It can't be the seventh day. So, take it
up with the author of Hebrews and stop
lying and saying that Christians have no
basis for this. No, you guys are just
stuck on spiritual milk and you want
everything in sound bite proof text
where it has to be only on this topic,
the verbatim fallacy. Show me one verse
that says go to church on Sunday. Show
me one verse that says go to church on
Saturday. It's just that's such an
inconsistent standard. But notice what
Thomas Watson, 17th century Puritan,
English Puritan, this is from his book,
The Ten Commandments. Notice what he
says about this quote. Now there's a
grand reason for changing of the Jewish
Sabbath to the Lord's day because this
puts us in the mind of the mystery of
our redemption by Christ. The reason why
God did institute the old Sabbath was
because God would have have it kept as a
memorial of the creation. But the Lord
hath now brought the first day of the
week in the room of it in memory of a
more glorious work than creation, and
that is redemption.
Great was the work of creation, but
greater was the work of redemption.
As it was said, Haggi 2:9, the glory of
the second temple was greater than the
glory of the first temple. So the glory
of the of of the redemption was greater
than the glory of the creation. Great
wisdom was seen in the curious making of
us, but more miraculous wisdom in saving
us.
Great power was seen in bringing us out
of nothing, creation x nahilo.
But greater power in helping us when we
were worse than nothing.
It it costs more to redeem us than to
create us.
In the creation, there was but speaking
a word. Psalm 148:5. In the redeeming of
us, there was shedding of blood.
The creation was the work of God's
fingers. Redemption was the work of his
arms.
In the creation, God gave us ourselves.
In the redemption, he gave us himself.
Wow. In the creation, God gave us
ourselves. In the redemption, he gave us
himself.
By creation, we have a life in Adam. By
redemption, we have life in Christ.
By creation, we had a right to an
earthly paradise, Eden. By redemption,
we have a title to a heavenly kingdom.
So that while Christ might change the
seventh day of the week into the first,
because this day puts us in mind of our
redemption, which is more glorious work
than the creation. Close quote.
Former Adventists, their heads are
exploding right now.
That's fine. Keep studying. You don't
have to agree with me. Christians
understand the law gospel distinction
and that this is part of understanding
around the law, not the gospel. But
obviously, folks, on this platform, I'm
going to be approaching things from my
vantage point.
These are the types of people the SDA
pioneers latched on to, stole their
arguments, but then twist them to fit
with the great controversy worldview.
Adventists hear this stuff and think
that sounds or former Adventists hear
this stuff and think that sounds like
Adventism. Well, yeah, because they
stole from other people because they're
a leech organization and then they twist
it by saying things like, "Well, it's
the seal of God. It's the
differentiating line between those who
are truly saved and those who aren't."
And all this other nonsense that's from
the Great Controversy.
And on this platform, I'm not going to
let them do that. Not gonna happen. I
was just talking with Jud Lake this past
week, SDA theologian and professor,
and he mentioned how much he loves the
Puritans. Well, friend, please read more
of them in this area. It's like you guys
are so close but a million miles shy.
Again, man, if this I if if swinging a
miss
were a theological system, it's this
system.
Watson does such an excellent job of
explaining how Jesus is better.
This is why the Christian church meets
on the new creation memorial. We're
celebrating this better new creation
work by being in Christ, the
accomplishment of redemption, the
promises that we have by being in him.
The seal is the Holy Spirit and pledge
and down payment of that which is a
product again of the new creation, not
the Sabbath being the seal.
The old memorial pointed forward to this
better.
And even in the new creation, the
memorial is just the memorial. It's not
the substance. The day is not the
substance. That's the other thing. They
get it completely off the rails,
thinking the day is the substance. No,
the day is the memorial. We meet every
seven days from that memorial
because the memorial points us to the
substance.
But even the new memorial, it still
points ahead to the awaiting of entering
into the eternal rest. Not just for our
souls, but for our physical bodies, into
the true promised land.
has nothing to do with the pope, nothing
to do with Romanism, nothing to do with
hating God's law, nothing to do with the
Council of Leysia, nothing to do with
Constantine or any of the other great
controversy bearing false witness in
violation of the ninth commandment that
Ellen White claims is from God, calling
God a liar by saying he's the one that
revealed this to her. It has everything
to do with new creation, something the
SDA church does not understand at all.
I've searched the Barri archives that
Ted was mentioning earlier, the Biblical
Research Institute, Adventist Biblical
Research Institute. There ain't a lick
of nothing in there about new creation
hardly. They are not prepared for this,
folks. Their old arguments are not going
to work on this platform. They might
work on other people. They might work on
Antonyomians and and all sorts of other
people that make other arguments. And
I'm not dogging on them. I'm just saying
it's not going to work on this platform.
I get SDAs that comment on the videos
all the time. It's like, do you guys
even bother to look where you're
commenting? We have a public-f facing
statement of faith. There's a whole
section on the law. There's a whole
section on the Sabbath. Yet, they still
comment on our videos. You think the Ten
Commandments are irrelevant? Yeah,
that's what Thomas Watson said, right?
That's what he says in his book, The Ten
Commandments, right?
They are totally stuck in the old
creation, wondering why the rest of us
aren't stuck there with them when we're
basking in the goodness of the gospel in
the new creation. enjoying the light
shining on us in the sun like a day at
the beach. Meaning Jesus by sun, not the
su Adventist.
Meanwhile, they're off in the shadow in
the cold with their back turned to the
son who's the substance of the shadow.
They need to stop lying. Every time they
make this claim, they're evidencing that
no, they're not the commandmentkeeping
church. They bear false witness
constantly and misrepresent Christians.
and they need to stop pointing to
lowhanging fruit like Christians who
just haven't studied this area as much
and are still growing and learning
as if it's their fault.
It's not their fault and I'm not
faulting them, but the SDA church and
her apologists like to try and
theologically bully Christians who maybe
don't understand the mechanics around
this as well, thinking they have some
slam dunk when they don't.
Not going to work. And you're not going
to bully Christians anymore. And come on
here, Adventists. Let's have a
discussion about it, okay? Let's see who
understands scripture, right?
Because this is only scratching the tip
of the iceberg if you think this is
everything we have. You're not going to
bully Christians anymore and think that
you have some slam dunk on people all
because they might be babes in Christ or
just haven't studied this area because
theology is a vast wide cate, you know,
has all sorts of topics and stuff.
people aren't aren't lost and not
Christians just because they don't agree
on this or because they they maybe don't
understand, etc. It's not the seal of
God. It's not the dividing line between
who's a Christian and who's not.
These people are still resting in
Christ. They still understand that
aspect. They maybe just haven't gotten
to the deeper aspects of it yet.
Now, let's look at Philip Schoff's
history of the Christian church. The SDA
church loves quoting Shaw, especially
the pioneers. Remember back when we were
responding to to Mark Finley, EJ Wagner,
Elllet Wagner, he claimed that no one
could argue with Shaoff's knowledge on
the facts of history.
Notice what he says.
The observance of Sunday originated in
the time of the apostles.
The time of the apostles, Adventists.
and ever since forms the basis of public
worship and its enobbling, sanctifying
and cheering influences in all Christian
lands. The Christian Sabbath is on the
one hand the continuation and the
regeneration of the Jewish Sabbath based
upon God's resting from the creation and
upon the fourth commandment of the
decalogue which as to its substance is
not merely a national application like
the ceremonial and civil law but of
universal import and perpetual validity
for mankind. It is on the other hand a
new creation of the gospel,
a memorial of the resurrection of Christ
and of the work of redemption completed
and divinely sealed thereby.
It rests, we may say, upon the
three-fold basis of the original
creation, the Jewish legislation, and
the Christian redemption,
and is rooted in the physical, the
moral, and the religious wants of our
nature.
It has a legal and and an evangelical
aspect. Like the law in general, the
institution of the Christian Sabbath is
a wholesome restraint upon upon the
people and a school master to lead them
to Christ.
But it is also strictly evangelical. It
was originally made for the benefit of
man like the family with which it goes
beyond the fall to the paradise of
innocence as the second institution of
God on earth. It was a delight to the
pious of the old dispensation and now
under the new. It is fraught with the
glorious memories and blessings of
Christ's resurrection and the outpouring
of the Holy Spirit. The Christian
Sabbath is the ancient Sabbath baptized
with fire and the Holy Ghost
regenerated, spiritualized, and
glorified. It is the connecting link of
creation and redemption, of paradise
lost and paradise regained, and a pledge
and preparation for the saints
everlasting rest in heaven.
This was said long before the SDA church
was around, folks.
And this isn't unique or original to Sha
either, by the way.
They have latched on to the language of
other people, but then twisted it to fit
their system.
Like I said, then former Adventists hear
this and think that sounds like
Adventism. Yeah. Because they latched on
other people and they're a leech
organization. And then they've twisted
things. This is why I call it
theological fog. They've confused people
who then hear stuff like this and think,
"Well, that sounds like you're giving
the Adventist an upper hand." Not even
close. Cuz if you understand the
details, this completely wants their
system. Completely dunks on it.
Schoff explains that a person is born
again, which is the seal Adventists, the
Holy Spirit, not the Seventh Day
Sabbath. And that pledge from God, which
is exactly what Paul calls the Holy
Spirit in Ephesians 1:14, is a promise
of the eternal rest we have awaiting us
with our maker. We celebrate that every
seven days from the new creation
memorial because Jesus is better.
There are a number of other places we
could look at which we're going to be
doing in a few weeks by the way,
dedicating an entire stream to that. But
Ted, the fourth commandment is a
pattern.
They were not following a Roman calendar
that was influenced that's influenced
your thinking. You guys read into the
commandments Saturday when it doesn't
say that.
It doesn't say that. It doesn't say
Sunday either. It doesn't matter what
you'd call the day. It's a pattern. It's
a pattern.
And it was to be observed every seven
days regardless of the cycle of the
calendar. It also didn't only
memorialize creation, it memorialized
redemption. You guys never quote
Deuteronomy 5. you only exclusively
quote Exodus 20 missing the bigger
picture which is what Hebrews 4 is
actually tying together for us which is
what Shaw was pointing out.
Jesus brought about a better creation
leading a better redemption as a better
Joshua and is a better mediator than
Moses bringing about a better Sabbath
and a better creation.
We are in the new creation now. It has a
new memorial
which is when Jesus entered his rest
which was on the first day not the
seventh day. That was God in creation
not in redemption.
We're in the better now.
Which is also why when you guys love to
appeal Jesus observed the seventh day
Sabbath
you again not looking at the full
picture. Yes he did but he changed that
habit postresurrection.
But because you guys refuse to actually
look at the Bible in total
proof texts here and there, you then
claim Christians have no clue what
they're talking about. They hate God's
law, etc. When no, you guys need to stop
assuming all Christians are the same,
especially former Adventists.
Again, they've taken concepts from other
people,
conveniently leaving out the central
aspect and component, which is new
creation. Gee, I wonder why.
But then you've then infused all sorts
of other ridiculousness into it, like
that it's the seal of God, the final
dividing line between those who are
saved and aren't saved, that it's
eternal, as if days are eternal when
days are a result of the sun and the
moon.
So if you're a former Adventist, realize
that this movement is an amalgamation of
other groups where they took things that
they liked specifically from
Presbyterianism, Methodism, and
restorationist Unitarianism and
formulated their systematic theology off
of that. Different discussion for a
different day. But it drives me mad when
they do this and then people hear
something like I just explained and say,
"Oh, that sounds like Adventism."
Yeah, because they're a leech
organization. And this is why I concede
nothing to them. Nothing. Not the law,
not the Sabbath, or any other doctrine.
And Christians shouldn't either. It
gives them a false sense of victory when
it shouldn't.
Like when people are afraid to concede
that the Sabbath is a memorial of
creation, that gives the SDAs an upper
hand falsely,
making them think because then they
point to Exodus 20:8 and you're caught
in a conundrum and you're like, well, it
doesn't say it's actually a memorial.
And then you get hung up on all these
things when it's like, "No, dude. Just
agree and say, "Right, but we need to
talk about old and new creation." Then
they're brain short circuits. I just did
this with an Adventist pastor not too
long ago. The dude was totally frazzled.
He had no clue where to go because he's
so used to people even arguing that
Sabbath is a part of of a memorial of
creation. They're so used to arguing at
that level that if you just concede and
go to the next step, it just completely
thwarts the whole thing.
Got to understand new creation, folks.
If you understand new creation, once it
clicks, I I'm telling you, once it
clicks, it's over. It's over.
This is the ancient argument that people
like Ignatius, Tertullian, and others
were using against the Judaizers of
their day.
Some of the reformers polished it up and
systematized it, but it's all rooted in
new creation.
Number six, false doctrines that are
circulating, and there are many.
There are misconceptions and false
doctrines circulating about the
salvation process. These false doctrines
diminish sanctification.
One false movement, you may not have
heard about it, and that's fine, but it
is circulating among some of our
university and college campuses. It's
called love reality
and it's been teaching this false
understanding about Christ's full
justifying and sanctifying
righteousness. Now these are derivatives
of the false doctrine of once-s saved
always saved which seventh day
Adventists do not believe.
Unfortunately, it is promoted that
behavior is not important since God
loves you and just don't worry about
what you're doing as long as you feel
embraced by God's love.
God's love is powerful, important,
but these false doctrines are very
dangerous and should not be accepted
since they destroy the entire
understanding of Christ's justifying and
sanctifying righteousness. We are
facing,
this is my opinion,
we are facing the shaking and sifting
period in the church right now. There
are those who are drifting out of a
clear understanding of who we are and
what we believe. Do not be tempted with
false doctrines that take you away from
God's remnant church. We have been
chosen for mission.
Ted, I'm still wondering why the great
controversy theme isn't properly
functioning as the great antidote to
theological division.
You guys assure us that theological
division is a hallmark sign of Babylon.
My friend, you guys are steeped in it.
Human sexuality, higher critical method,
rejection of the sanctuary and the
investigative judgment, now university
and college campuses and love reality.
Sounds like a lot of division to me,
dude.
It's just crazy to me how SDAs cannot
see the glaring hypocrisy. Ted's entire
thesis is damage control over all this
division and imploring leadership to
stand against it.
Yet there's supposed to be the bastion
of unity and everyone else is totally
confused and divided. My goodness, man.
Time to wake up.
He also misrepresented those that hold
to once- saved always saved by equating
it with whatever this fringe love
reality group is saying. I don't hold to
once saved always saved which is a very
particular thing. It's not a blanket
term folks for any person that affirms
eternal security of which I do hold to
because I'm a monarchist
but I know lots of people who hold the
once saved always saved and they don't
believe behavior doesn't matter Ted. I
know some that do, but Adventists love
scapegoating. Once saved, always saved.
Just like they love scapegoating
Calvinism. Everything's, oh, that's
Calvinism.
Like, okay, I guess Lutheran are
Calvinists now. Anglicans are Calvinist.
Just whenever you take umbrage with
their sanctuary model of salvation, they
love to claim if you only believe once
saved, always saved. If that's
eliminated, then it's just the logical
conclusion.
Again, it just blows my mind that they
say stuff like this that does not
logically follow at all.
And every Armenian or provisionist out
there is thinking, "Uh, what?"
Then he mentions the shaking. Oh,
Ted, you guys have been saying the
shaking's been happening for over 150
years.
It's like the ultimate SDA cope
to wax over the fact that people are
waking up to this ridiculousness of SDA
theology, Ellen White's blunders, etc.
It's always labeled as evidence of the
shaking happening.
Then again, there definitely is a
shaking that's happening. It's just not
the one that the SDA church thinks. It's
God shaking this movement by bringing
his people out, which is what we pray on
this platform. We're used by him to be a
part of. He doesn't need us, but that's
the desire. Lord, please use us as a
means to reach people caught in this
gospel wasteland of a movement who are
parched and in need of living water.
But seriously, they will be clinging to
the shaking excuse for as long as long
as the movement exists to try and
dismiss people leaving as some sort of
evidence of prophecy being fulfilled.
All of these 19th century groups have
this. It's all embedded in their system
and they all point to people who leave
to cement the people that are there
further in. Number seven, loss of the
sense of urgency. In the Advent
movement, in various parts of the
Seventh Day Adventist Church, there are
those who seem to have lost their their
sense of urgency in the second coming of
Christ, which should permeate every
aspect of Seventh Day Adventist life.
The current deteriorating
world conditions should awaken us to the
urgent need to proclaim the three angels
messages of Revelation 14 in
anticipation of Christ's soon return.
Jesus indicated three times in
Revelation 22 that he is coming quickly.
We are living at the end of the end of
time. So let's live with that sense of
urgency that will allow the Holy Spirit
to work through each of us to share the
need to fall at the foot of the cross
being prepared for the second coming
through the grace of Jesus Christ.
Ted, people have lost their urgency
because they have advent fatigue.
Mark Finley talks about this. They've
been beat over the head day in and day
out that Jesus is coming tomorrow.
And nothing they do in your system has
them ready.
Christians are always ready regardless
of when it comes because we understand
union with Christ. But that's not enough
in your system. Everything's about doing
more, more, more to be prepared, and
they never feel adequate. So, they keep
doing more, more, more, and the cycle
never ends. At a certain point, people
become exhausted.
Notice that Ted ties the heralding of
their special special message as the
thing that will have a person prepared
for Christ's return.
That special present truth message that
only they have. Yet, the majority of
them don't even feel prepared. They're
fatigued, burned out, and exhausted.
They're losing their urgency. Yet, this
is the message that's supposed to be
backed by a 365 money back guarantee
called the great controversy theme, the
theory of everything, the God particle,
the insight into the mind of God.
Yet, people are losing their urgency and
becoming fatigued.
Ted, at the San Antonio general session,
you lambasted SDAs for not doing their
job well enough. That was two sessions
ago, so almost a decade ago, saying they
weren't doing their job well enough and
that Jesus should have been back by now
if Adventists were doing their job. Do
you think that maybe beating SDAs over
the head like that maybe played a part
in the defeist mindset that you're now
experiencing
leading to the loss of urgency? just a
thought. But also,
this is another area where you guys are
caught in a big old catch 22.
On the one hand, you guys claim the
Sunday law isn't a conditional prophecy
from Ellen White. It's guaranteed to
happen. You even referenced this in your
annual council last year.
Yet you guys claim Jesus could come at
any minute, which would mean he could
come before the Sunday law arrives,
putting you in quite the catch.
He mentioned John saying in the
revelation that Jesus is coming quickly.
Again, Ted, that was written long before
you guys were around.
It doesn't automatically necessitate
that it means tomorrow. It could be the
case, and praise God if it is. Let's go.
But even if not, that's fine, too. He
calls the shots. He's ruling and
reigning. He isn't waiting to complete
some investigation into sin and to
vindicate the character of God like you
guys claim. Or that there aren't enough
people on the earth keeping the law
perfectly, demonstrating God's law is
fair and the great controversy and all
this other stuff. That's not why he
hasn't returned yet. Mr. and Mrs.
Adventist, if you feel fatigue and you
think it's because of those things,
that's not it. Read the book of Hebrews.
all of his enemies are still being made
a foottool. This goes back to the good
news of the kingdom of God and that the
Messiah has come and taken his throne.
It's after all of his enemies are made
his foottool that he returns and he'll
destroy the last enemy which is death. 1
Corinthians 15, casting it and the
contents of Hades out of his kingdom
into the lake of fire. Nothing to do
with the investigative judgment and
great controversy nonsense.
Number eight, loss of identity as God's
remnant church. Some members seem to
have lost the identity of and reason for
the 7th Day Adventist Church. We are the
remnant church of God,
not just another denomination. God
called us to lift up Christ and his
righteousness by preaching those three
angels messages, turning people back to
the true worship of God. He has called
the Seventh Day Adventist Church as a
unique movement with a unique message on
a unique mission all centered in Jesus
Christ and his mission of salvation. We
are called and chosen for mission to
prepare people for the Lord's imminent
second coming. Do not be confused
as to who Seventh Day Adventists are. We
are God's special messengers and his
remnant church. Do not allow mission
drift in our church entities and
institutions which results in loss of
identity. And let me speak to all union
presidents and division presidents.
You are the chairs
of our educational institutions.
take an interest in everything about
those institutions and especially in
what is being taught in our religion
classes.
Realize that we need to re-energize our
entities and institutions because we are
chosen for mission. Our name preaches a
powerful sermon. It says who we are. It
explains where we've come from. Christ,
God, the Father, the Son, the Holy
Spirit
creating us. We worship.
Look at the audience, folks.
This woman in the front here,
she looks like she's crying.
Like, does anyone there
look happy?
They look like a a group of people that
are just
being disciplined.
I mean, my goodness, man. What a sad
scene. Talk about the look of defeat and
beat down.
Avenous, it doesn't have to be like
this. There's actual good news
that we want you guys to come and know.
It just Oh my good. Look at him on the
seventh day Sabbath. And it says where
we're going when we're understanding the
Adventist part of it that we we're going
to be going home to heaven soon. So be
excited about being a Seventh Day
Adventist and chosen for mission. Know
what that means and share the three
angels messages with everyone. Number
I just did a video a few weeks ago.
Present truth and the SDA church in
identity crisis.
Ted, the reason you guys are in an
identity crisis is because of present
truth.
It's not only been your guys' get out of
jail free card, but the flip side of
that card is that it's also your
movement's Achilles heel.
Every time you guys have pivoted using
present truth, it only creates more
problems.
like your claim earlier that the first
apartment work of the sanctuary was
completed at Calvary despite Ellen
saying Jesus was doing that work from
the ascension until 1844 and virtually
all of your pioneers that I'm aware of
absolutely disagreeing with you that any
sort of atonement even took place at the
cross.
It's because of present truth that you
have liberal strains and factions within
your movement. They all cling to present
truth to support the idea of being with
the times. Adventism being a big tent
and so on.
It's also present truth that's caused
your movement to become Babylon
according to your own definition.
Here you are talking about people losing
the SDI SDA identity and the mission of
the SDA church.
That sounds like more division, my
friend. that's supposed to be
exclusively reserved for us diluted,
confused Protestants, not you guys. Yet,
what I keep hearing from you is how much
division and confusion there is in your
ranks and you're doing damage control
trying to get it under control.
But I'm glad he admitted though that
SDAs have a unique mission. Did you
catch that?
It's not the same as Christians, folks.
I know Adventists hate when I say this
and point it out. Sorry. Truth matters.
The SDA church does not share the same
mission as the Christian church. It's
not to take the same Christ and the same
gospel to a lost and dying world,
furthering Christ's kingdom throughout
all nations. No, it's to take their
cursed three angels gospel, that's a
different gospel than the apostles
taught, to everyone, including
Christians. We're their primary focus.
Most of the time it isn't even to tell
people about Christ. It's to try and
convince them of the seventh day Sabbath
and the health message, which is what
the third angel's message supposedly is.
So Ted, thank you for admitting this.
Present truth is one of the hallmark
signs of a cult
where they claim to have a special
unique mission and revelation from God
that only they have to take to everyone
else. Major red flags. But again, Ted, I
want to reiterate, you were on the
Seeking What They Saw podcast right
before I was.
The entire thesis of the series that
they are doing is what is an Adventist?
And people from all across the spectrum
giving their own personal flavor and
definition.
This is why I chuckle at the thought of
people saying stuff like Adventism is a
diverse, broad, hard to really define
thing that all the liberal leaning SDAs
love to try and posture. That's the
exact opposite of what Adventism is. And
here Ted is reiterating that same thing.
Adventism is very clearly defined. It's
very specific. Not this big tent of
malaise of sort of there's a huge
spectrum and none of us really know. No,
that's a modern-day spin and facelift to
try and appeal to a different audience
of people. Identity crisis is a perfect
description of how to describe Adventism
with present truth being the hallmark
sign of a movement that is in one.
Number nine, false accusations about the
church's relationship with ecumenism.
The 7th Day Adventist Church is
absolutely not involved in compromising
ecumenism with other religious bodies or
movements. Absolutely underline that
nothing can compromise our biblical
understanding of truth and nothing ever
will. We believe in making friends with
those in other religious
excuse me and public groups to help them
understand who we are and how we
positively contribute to society through
following Christ's method of helping
people physically, mentally, socially,
and spiritually. I meet many public
officials and I share with them who
Seventh Day Adventists are and what we
believe ending if possible and almost
all except with a prayer for these
public leaders, their families, their
countries. What a privilege for all of
us to witness for the Lord in many
different settings. The presence of
Seventh Day Adventists in various groups
or public uh settings with public
officials does not in any way imply that
7th day Adventists have become
ecumenical or given up any fundamental
biblical belief or ever will. Even some
pictures of events are misrepresented or
taken out of context to attempt to show
that the church is involved in ecumenism
when it is simply involved in public
affairs activities, helping share
religious liberty values and acquaint
people with the beliefs of 7th day
Adventist. Again, let me assure all of
you in this room and those watching, the
7th Day Adventist Church is absolutely
not involved in ecumenism or
compromising our biblical beliefs.
Do not believe any false accusations
that the 7th Day Adventist Church has
become Babylon. Yes, we're sinful. I
understand that. We all are. But we're
not Babylon. We've never compromised and
will not biblical truth. We are God's
remnant church with a unique biblical
message that will never be compromised.
We know what we're going to face in the
future. The book, The Great Controversy
tells us, and we believe in the
prophetic understanding of our role in
the final events of Earth's history as
outlined in the books of Daniel,
Matthew, and Revelation. And of course,
that wonderful book, The Great
Controversy. I hope you're distributing
it. Nancy and I shared that book with a
list of family and neighbors just a few
weeks ago.
I hope you're sharing that book.
Dude,
whenever they rant about ecumenism, I
get a terrible headache.
Not because of hearing them talk about
it, but because of how hard my palm hits
my face.
Ted, your movement was born out of
ecumenism.
OG Adventism, Millerism, was an
ecumenical movement. Yet now all of a
sudden they're fearful of ecumenism. And
you have all these people online
speculating that Ted's a Jesuit plant
and he's hitching the mainline SDA
church up with popery and so on.
But jot this down for when you hear
SDA's try and claim, "No, no, we're just
Christians like you, brother. No, you're
not. You're your own thing. I'd love for
you to be my brother and sister in
Christ."
But that can't happen when you affirm
the damnable heresies of this church,
namely a false Christ, a false trinity,
and a false gospel.
I can link arms with Lutheran, Baptists,
non-toon believers.
despite not being any of those myself
because we have the same mission, God,
and gospel. That's the foundation.
They simply have differing opinions on
secondary matters. Adventists do not.
It's entirely other.
They might borrow Christian language,
but they do not mean the same thing.
Notice he said, "We're not against
making friends in other groups and
explaining who we are and how we
positively contribute to society." aka
sheep stealing
because let's not forget Ellen White's
advice to an Adventist missionary in
Europe in the early days.
They didn't have connections or real
roots there yet. And this was her advice
about how to go about proitizing
Christians.
Quote, "The great prejudice of the
Jewish nation of priests, here we are
using the Jews as an analogy again. and
rulers was stirred up against Christ
because the people preferred to listen
to Jesus rather than to them. The very
same feelings of prejudice will be
manifest in the priests and rulers of
this time.
We can do nothing that would close up
the way before us in this country,
talking about Europe, like taking a
position of superiority and putting
before the people that we consider them
heathen. In truth, they are worse than
heathen. But this were not to tell them.
The clergy,
that's key, the clergy consider
themselves as teachers, highly
religious, and their churches send out
missionaries to the work of converting
the savages. But to have the implication
that a similar work must be done for
them, the clergy Christians, they would
consider the worst kind of insult. Close
quote.
So notice it's about the it's about
Christians, not lost people. Christian
pastors and religious leaders. She tells
this missionary that the same feeling
that rose up amongst the Jewish leaders
of Jesus's day would also manifest in
the religious leaders of their day upon
hearing that they need to be converted
to Adventism.
This would offend them because they're
sending out their own missionaries
and they would be offended to hear that
they themselves are worse than the
heathen and a similar work is needed for
them. They would take that as an insult
worse than heathen. Christian pastors
and leaders inspired pen folks
don't take the bait.
This movement thinks our going to church
on Sunday and belief that God sustains
the souls of humans to be a deception of
Satan, demonic in origin, that we are
lost and deceived. They love to try and
buddy buddy up with us for the purpose
of trying to evangelize and call us to
come out of Babylon and join them. But
when you peel back all the layers
of them trying to portray Adventism as
this nice happy kumbaya around the fire
sort of thing at the end of the day
that's what they think about Christians.
Okay.
But then he said don't think that we've
become Babylon
Ted. It isn't pictures of you shaking
hands with some world leaders that's
supposedly a Jesuit
that makes you guys Babylon. It's your
own definition from your own prophetus
who said Protestants are Babylon because
we're supposedly doctrally confused and
have no unity.
Yet this entire speech is about you
addressing all of the disunityity and
doctrinal confusion that is spread
throughout your movement. I mean, come
on, dude. I feel like we read this quote
every week now, but here we go again.
Spirit of Prophecy Volume 4, page 232.
Quote, "The term Babylon derived from
Babel and signifying confusion
is applied in scripture to the various
forms of false or apostate religion.
But the message announcing the fall of
Babylon must apply to some religious
body that was once pure and has become
corrupt. It cannot be the Roman church
which is here meant for that church has
been in in a fallen condition for many
centuries. But how appropriate the
figure figure is applied to the
Protestant churches all professing to
derive their doctrines from the Bible
yet divided into almost innumerable
sects. The unity for which Christ prayed
for does not exist. Instead of one Lord,
one faith, one baptism, there are
numberless conflicting creeds and
theories. Religious faith appears so
confused and discordant that the world
know not what to believe is truth. God
is not in all this. It's the work of
man, the work of Satan. Ted, you are
confusing or you are kidding yourself,
sir. You guys are one of the most
doctrinally divided sex I've ever come
across. And I don't say that with glee.
It's just the truth.
You've evidenced it for us in your own
presentation tonight.
This entire thing has been about
doctrinal confusion and errors flooding
the movement. And here you are seeking
to write the ship.
No one's saying you guys haven't done
any good in the world. So have Mormons.
So have all sorts of groups. That
doesn't mean you guys still aren't
pedaling a false god and a false gospel.
Niceness and sincerity do not give
someone qualified immunity before God.
And on top of it, you're spreading the
great controversy which only furthers
the spread of the false gospel and false
Christ.
Number 10, challenges to the authority
of the church. The church understands
that the Holy Spirit works through
structured organizations that were
organized by heaven itself. The 7th Day
Adventist Church was uniquely organized
as God's last day Advent movement to
proclaim the three angels messages and
the final loud cry to a world that is
desperately in need of the message of
Christ's righteousness, grace, and
salvation. The church is built on a
representative committee system that
allows for the Holy Spirit's direct
intervention in how decisions are made.
And we will make decisions right in this
room and have
The Holy Spirit guides leaders and
church members in making decisions. When
committee decisions at the worldwide
level are made based on biblical and
spirit of prophecy instruction and
guided by humble prayer, personal
opinions and convictions are to be laid
aside. Spirit of prophecy tells us that.
I could quote that to you. And the
authority of the world church is to be
respected and accepted. When people or
organizations do not follow biblical
principles of church authority, the
world church cannot simply fire people
or get rid of organizations without a
very careful biblical approach of trying
to help people realize their mistakes.
The church structure is not a command
and control or hierarchical
administrative arrangement. The church
structure is built on common biblical
beliefs, policy agreements, and
congenial recognition that we work
together under the power of the Holy
Spirit. Although there are disciplinary
measures that can be used, the church
works carefully to bring people back to
unity in Christ through the Holy
Spirit's power. The Bible and the spirit
of prophecy are replete with counsel
guiding us to accept the authority of
the world church in session where we
make decisions on fundamental biblical
beliefs, church manual items, governance
decisions and other specific topics
brought to the world church
representation. The spirit of prophecy
speaks about the poison of criticism. To
avoid this, we are to work in harmony
with God and each other at the local
church level, the conference mission
level, the union level, and the division
level. All decisions and the world
level. All decisions should be made in
accordance and cooperation with
worldwide church decisions. The
authority of the church is found in a
worldwide representative process that is
directed by the Holy Spirit. With
Christlike humility, we are to respect
the authority of the church and all at
all levels as God leads his people in
the final days of Earth's history. We
are counseledled in the spirit of
prophecy. Press together. Press
together. Press together. Do not drift
into congregationalism.
realize we are a worldwide body of
believers proclaiming the Lord's return,
united in God's biblical truth and
chosen for mission.
Again,
Ted equates the message of salvation
with the Adventist Church's three angels
gospel, evidencing that yes, the
Adventist church has a different gospel.
Adventists, those of you who comment on
our videos saying that I'm lying, I'm
misrepresenting, I don't know what I'm
talking about. and so on. There you go.
He keeps saying it over and over and
over. Salvation is tied to your guys'
novel gospel, the SDA pillar doctrines.
These
Yes, we supposedly have to believe all
of this to be saved. That's supposedly
the fullness of the gospel restored, to
use Herbert Douglas's words.
None of this is the gospel. It's a bunch
of theological positions that you guys
call the gospel, but it isn't.
And Ted said earlier that veganism and
vegetarianism doesn't save anyone. Yet,
it's a part of your gospel message.
And Paul says that the gospel is the
power of God to salvation for all that
believe it. Romans 1:16-1 17. Which
means yes, you guys are calling this
stuff the gospel.
So yes, you are then saying these
doctrines are the power of God to
salvation for all that believe them
even though Paul wasn't preaching this
novel message
as we saw the review and herald openly
state.
So what Paul believed the power of God
to salvation is was not what the
Adventist church is calling the gospel.
But then he said the Holy Spirit has
direct intervention in how decisions are
made in the SDA church. Ted, there's no
need for you to quote it for us, as I'll
happily do so. What he's referencing,
folks, is principles for Christian
Leadership, page 105. Quote,
I've been shown that no man's judgment
should be surrendered to the judgment of
any one man. But
when the judgment of the general
conference, which is the highest
authority that God has upon the earth,
is exercised, private independence and
private judgment must not be maintained,
but be surrendered.
Your error was in persistently
maintaining your private judgment of
your duty against the voice of the
highest authority the Lord has upon the
earth." Close quote.
So she wrote this to brother A, whoever
that was,
as a rebuke to him, having his own
private judgment that needed to be
surrendered to the general conference,
who when in session is the highest
authority God has on earth.
Decisions are made, Ted said, based on
biblical and spirit of prophecy
instruction.
Oh, no, no. We just believe the Bible.
Yeah. Okay.
On top of that, the general session or
the general conference in session is
also an authority that apparently acts
with infallibility if it's a process
that the Holy Spirit has direct
intervention on.
So don't try and tell us you guys only
believe the Bible. I mean, what a joke.
No, you believe what the great
controversy theme tells you the Bible
means and what the general conference
tells you must be believed.
And if you're out of step with that, you
have to surrender that belief. Also
interesting to note that, Ted, if the
Holy Spirit isn't actually involved the
way you claim he is in this direct
intervention,
then you're violating the third
commandment
and you're bearing God's name falsely,
claiming that he's behind something that
he isn't, which would mean you're not
the commandmentkeeping church.
Number 11, misunderstandings about the
role of the spirit of prophecy as given
by God through the writings of Ellen G.
White. There are constant attacks on the
spirit of prophecy as represented by the
writings of Ellen G. White. The spirit
of prophecy was given by the seventh to
the seventh day Adventist church by God
as a precious gift and is as applicable
today as when it was written. The
voluminous writings of Ellen White were
given by God to lead his remnant church
in all areas of life, pointing us back
to Christ and his holy word. All the
writings of the spirit of prophecy are
instructive in these last days of
earth's history, including such books as
testimonies for the church and the great
controversy.
I want to tell you, I personally believe
every word of God's counsel in the Bible
and the spirit of prophecy. I hope you
do, too.
Unfortunately, there are those who
disparage, downgrade, and repudiate the
spirit of prophecy. I urge you to have a
strong commitment to the reading of the
word of God and the spirit of prophecy
and follow God's instructions for his
last day remnant people who are
proclaiming Christ's powerful messages
of salvation and prophecy.
Notice Adventist
Ted doesn't play word games when it
comes to the spirit of prophecy being a
reference to Ellen White's writings.
Christian, some Adventists love to play
hard ball on this to try and make it
look like someone doesn't know what
they're talking about. They'll say, "No,
what? You're confused. Spirit of
prophecy is referring to Jesus speaking,
not Ellen White's writings, you clueless
critic." Right? which you guys think is
contained in Ellen White's writings as
Ted so plainly stated.
But he makes quite the admission. He
says personally he believes every word
of God's counsel in the Bible and the
spirit of prophecy.
Even though the words aren't supposed to
be God's, it's supposed to be thought
inspiration.
Nevertheless, there you go. He views
them both to be from the same source.
How they can't see that this is the two
being equal is beyond me. Cope mental
gymnastics. Like
yet Adventists will still repeat and
comment on our videos that the SDA
church doesn't put her writings on the
same level as scripture. You're
confused.
The woman claims you can't even
understand scripture without the lesser
light guiding you. that if you abandon
her writings, it's a one-way ticket to
predition where you'll eventually
abandon the Bible altogether.
That to reject her writings is to not to
is not to reject her, but to insult and
reject the spirit of God.
That they aren't merely her opinion and
on and on and on, which I feel like
we've looked at 5 million times on this
channel. Yet, Adventists will insist and
repeat that the SDA church doesn't
esteem her writings to be equal with
scripture. Again, constant catch22 and
cog and a cognitive dissonance.
And again, Ted equates the SDA mess with
salvation.
This is the third or fourth time he's
done this.
So when Adventists try and tell you,
"No, no, no. We're just Christians like
you."
No, you're not. You have a unique
message that's supposedly the salvific
message and after it's shared with you
and you reject it because of all of its
errors and flaws, many of which we've
looked at here just tonight, you'll be
damned.
They have a fundamentally different me
message that they're taking to the
world. It's not what the apostles were
preaching. It's not 2,000 years old.
The Christian faith is 2,000 years old,
folks. It's a straight chain back to the
apostles.
It's not some present truth thing that's
like now they love to try and appeal to
the reformers making the reformers
restorationists. That's not what was
going on there. The reformers still
considered themselves Catholics.
Number 12, lack of understanding the
true meaning of the seventh day Sabbath
as God's sign of his creatorship and
redemptive power in our lives. Christ's
loving plan of salvation produces our
loyalty of love to him, resulting in our
receiving his seal of the seventh day
keeping as opposed to following the
false day of Sunday worship which
results in Babylonian confusion and
ultimately receiving the mark of the
beast. It's not yet, but it will come.
We are to uplift the sanctity and
sacredness of the seventh day Sabbath,
guarding the edges of the Sabbath,
following the injunctions of the fourth
commandment, and showing respect to God
with appropriate spiritual activities on
the Sabbath day.
No sir, you are greatly confused.
As was already demonstrated, you are
stuck in the old creation.
The first day has nothing to do with
Satan or the Pope. This is your great
controversy worldview clouding your
judgment.
Not just there, but claiming the Sabbath
is the seal of God. No, it isn't.
For those former Adventists that think
what Shaoff and other Christians are
saying regarding the first day being the
Christian Sabbath just being a onetoone
with what the SDAs are claiming but on a
different day. Perfect example.
No, it's not the case at all.
Nowhere does scripture call the Sabbath
the seal of God. Ted,
this is your great controversy worldview
overriding the plain reading of the
Bible that you've implored us to
utilize.
Let's look at the plain reading of the
Bible. Okay, folks.
Ephesians 1.
Get your Bible out. Ephesians 1. We're
almost done.
11-14.
Plain reading of the Bible, Ted.
In him, that's a term of union with
Christ.
In him we have obtained an inheritance,
having been predestined according to the
purpose of him who works all things
according to the counsel of his will. So
that we who were the first to hope in
Christ might be to the praise of his
glory in him union with Christ. You also
when you heard the word of truth, what
is that? the gospel of your salvation,
not the everlasting three angels end
times present truth special novel
message.
The I guess the limited gospel that only
the apostles had.
When you heard the word of truth, the
gospel of your salvation and believed in
him.
Faith comes by hearing, hearing by the
word of God. How will they hear without
a preacher?
You were sealed with the promised Holy
Spirit who is the guarantee of our
inheritance until we acquire possession
of it to the praise of his glory. Very
simple. When a person hears the word of
truth proclaimed, which is the gospel of
salvation, the person and work of Jesus
Christ,
you're a sinner. God's coming back to
judge the living and the dead one day.
You're going to give an account for your
life. Unless you're found hidden in
Jesus Christ, it's going to be a bad day
for you. So turn to Christ, find
forgiveness. You can receive all the
benefits of being in Christ, being
united to him. He's God in flesh, the
second person of the triune God. God
himself came into creation, died, died a
sinner's death that he didn't deserve on
behalf of sinners.
Lived a sinless, perfect life, meeting
the demands of the law perfectly in and
of himself. You can in him be found as
though you kept those demands perfectly.
Trust in him today. A person does that.
Oh God, I'm a sinner. Please forgive me.
Please have mercy on me, God. A genuine
profession. God will steal them with the
promised Holy Spirit who is then a
guarantee of that inheritance until they
acquire possession of it. Like I was
saying about the Sabbath, the true
eternal promised land that we wait and
arrive at.
Very simple.
But no, we can't have that
plain didactic passage of scripture,
spiritual milk level stuff.
Adventists love to try and say, "No, no,
no. There's two seals to try and get
around this. Sorry, friend. The Holy
Spirit is the seal of salvation, not the
Sabbath. There isn't a seal of
salvation, which is the Holy Spirit, God
himself, and then a seal of the law. And
you need both and all the other mental
gymnastics SDAs have to try and perform
to make the great controversy theme
work.
Because the SDA church doesn't actually
understand the Sabbath is ultimately
about Jesus, not a day
about resting in Christ and celebrating
that eternal rest that we look forward
to.
that the day is the memorial, not the
substance. They botched the Bible
entirely.
The day is not the substance. Ted, I
really wish you guys could get this.
It's like when it click, I've seen it
click for people and it's just like you
can just tell there's like something
that it's like flipping a light switch
on. It's like it's like life something
happens in the person where they're just
like whoa and then it clicks and there's
no way to unsee it. That's what I want
for you.
But you guys have so elevated a day
which is the memorial not the substance.
Jesus is the substance. Resting in him
is the substance. We celebrate that on
the memorial of the new creation.
The seal is the Holy Spirit of all that.
Not a day.
Stop telling people Christians have no
biblical basis for their belief. And
stop trying to kid yourself that you
guys believe the Bible as it plainly
reads. You don't.
You don't. I just How can you even argue
this, Adventist? It's just It's cope.
You're You're just I understand, folks.
You want it to be true. You truly
believe it. I get it. But you have to
make a decision.
When you can't even believe something as
basic as that, but you're convinced you
have revelation figured out. Okay,
there's a problem. There's a problem.
He equates the first day with the mark
of the beast. So, get this, folks.
We're going to be doing a deep dive on
this, like I said, in a few weeks and a
stream dedicated to this. But, let's
just look at one example now, okay? It's
going to be quick. We're almost done. I
know we're at four hours. This is crazy,
but we need to do all this. These live
streams are the marathon streams to
really go deep on this stuff. Okay?
Watch this in multiple sessions if you
need to. Come back. I'm going to add
timestamps, all that good stuff.
Let's look at one example. They claim or
the claim is is that when a national
turned international Sunday law comes
down the pike, at that point the mark of
the beast will begin getting issued
because you're obeying and following man
and not God supposedly. Okay, let's read
Matthew 28 1-10. SDAs always b and scoff
at this when we reference it and they'll
say that isn't a church service. Yet
they completely yet again miss the
substance
in their dedication to their tradition.
Okay. Matthew 28
1-10.
Now after the Sabbath toward the dawn of
the first day of the week, we're going
to talk about this phrase here because
that this the the word that's used for
Sabbath there and the phrase first day
of the week is actually the exact same
word. So I'm going to argue it actually
says first day Sabbath. But
nevertheless, even with that aside,
toward the dawn of the first day of the
week, Mary Magdalene and the other Mary
went to see the tomb. And behold, there
was a great earthquake. For an angel of
the Lord descended from heaven, and came
and rolled back the stone, and sat on
it. His appearance was like lightning,
and his clothing white as snow. And for
fear of him, the guards trembled and
became like dead men. But the angel said
to the woman, "Do not be afraid, for I
know that you seek Jesus who was
crucified. He's not here, for he has
risen."
As he said, "Come see the place where he
lay."
Then go quickly and tell his disciples
that he's risen from the dead. And
behold, he's going before you to
Galilee. There you will see him. See, I
have told you." So they departed quickly
from the tomb with fear and great joy
and ran to tell his disciples. And
behold, Jesus met them and said,
"Greetings."
And they came up and took hold of his
feet and worshiped him. Then Jesus said
to them, "Do not be afraid. Go and tell
my brothers to go to Galilee, and there
they will see me." So notice
both Marys after hearing the gospel from
an angel, a messenger, they were told
the good news. He's risen.
They believe that message. They believe
the gospel.
And then go to meet Jesus who is
present.
We're told he met with them.
The word of God, which is what Jesus's
words are, is spoken over them.
Upon doing so, they cling to him and
worship him.
After doing so, they're then sent out by
Christ himself to take the gospel to
others.
This is exactly what the substance of
the church gathering is.
We leave our place of dwelling. We meet
with Jesus who is present in a special
way. We worship him. The word of God is
spoken over us, washing us in his word.
We then partake of him at his table in
the supper and are then sent out to the
world to take the gospel. All of this
happening on the first day.
You mean to tell me that because they
aren't in a formalized building with an
organized liturgy like SDA is trying to
argue, that means this isn't exactly
what the Christian church does?
No. Duh. It was the literal infancy of
the new creation. At the very first day
of it being inaugurated, the church
didn't meet in public buildings until
centuries later.
That doesn't mean the substance of what
the church does isn't all present there.
Hello.
Yet, according to Ted and the SDA
church, what the Mary's did will one day
be the mark of the beast because the
pope is going to be making a three-fold
pact with Protestants and spiritualism.
No, the truth is you guys are filtering
everything through the great controversy
theme and it's Christians that are
plainly reading the Bible.
But also, Ted, you just got done talking
about the lack of urgency that your
members are currently experiencing and
how imminency is a core to your
identity.
But now you assure us the Sunday law
will come, which means Jesus won't
return until that happens.
I I don't understand how you guys can't
see the issue here. Have you not thought
through these things?
He mentions the proper injunctions of
following the Sabbath and guarding its
edges. This is the problem all seventh
day sabotarians face. Since they don't
realize Jesus is the substance and the
day is the memorial that points to that,
they have to have their own arbitrary
standards of how one keeps the Sabbath,
which produces a whole spectrum in and
of itself amongst them. Just ask 10
different Adventists how you keep the
Sabbath. You'll get 12 different
answers.
The only level of continuity is at the
base layer saying, "Well, we go to
church on Saturday and we don't do our
worldly job." But beyond that, good
luck. Some go out to eat. Others say
it's strictly off limits. Others watch
TV. Others say it's strictly off limits.
It's all a grabag of subjectivity, which
is 100% a result of not actually
understanding the substance.
But also, Ted, why do you guys ignore
all of Ellen White's extra additions to
the Sabbath? The constant excuse on this
is that those were all injunctions of
her day that aren't applicable anymore
in this day and age. Yet earlier, you
claimed that the spirit of prophecy is
timeless and applicable to all
generations after.
We have an article on this, folks, by
the way, for those that are curious of
of seeing all of these extra biblical
additions that she added. And notice,
you can look this up on uh on the
website here. What did Ellen White add
to the Sabbath command?
My fa my my personal favorite is here
toward the end. No boisterous noise on
the Sabbath. No loud tone commands,
but also food needs to be extra bland on
the Sabbath.
All right. Okay, it's just rank
legalism. And Ted wonders why they get
labeled as such.
Ted, you guys don't follow this.
Adventists take naps on Saturdays. Ellen
said that's not to be done. Adventists
bathe on Saturdays. It's not supposed to
be done. Cooking isn't supposed to be
done. Yet, the large majority do. And on
and on. I've heard the excuse on the
bathing one. Well, in that day, it was a
lot of work to bathe. You had to walk
down and get water and
Yeah. Okay.
I really wish Adventists could come to
know the substance of the Sabbath and
rest in Christ and realize a day is not
the substance.
Giving a 24-hour rotation around the sun
in almost divine characteristic that
equals God himself. It just
number 13 and you saw it the other day
in our presentation by David Trim.
Confusion regarding the state of the
dead. Many unbiblical understandings
about life after death are being
promoted. Many local beliefs around this
world confuse people. The occult,
spiritualism, and satanic influences are
growing. The worldwide entertainment
industry promotes spiritualism. Avoid
all efforts, evil influences, and
programming that destroy the biblical
understanding of the state of the dead.
The devil plans overwhelming delusions
at the end of time through mysticism and
unbiblical understandings regarding life
after death. Satan will even attempt to
duplicate Christ's return. Refute any
attempts to overpower your thinking by
relying only on what you read in God's
word.
Ted, you guys don't believe only what's
read in God's word.
I mean, come on.
You just said you guys aren't part of
Babylon because there's no ecumenism
taking place. Yet now you claim there's
a lot of doctrinal confusion taking
place within the movement regarding the
state of the dead. Add that to the list.
Your prophetist said doctrinal confusion
and division is Babylon. I mean, hello.
Do you not hear yourself?
You rail against what others believe
about the intermediate state, saying
it's a major tool of Satan to deceive.
But Ted, you guys have a false gospel.
The greatest deception of Satan is the
great apostasy.
Falling away from the gospel of Jesus
Christ or outright rejection of it.
You guys are so concerned about what
other people believe about the
intermediate state, yet Satan has your
movement.
It doesn't matter if you guys think
you're correct about the state of the
dead when the state of your soul is dead
in a false gospel, sir.
And I mean that seriously. I'm not
trying to be shock jock or whatever. We
are concerned about you guys.
You have hysteria around all this
secondary stuff. Yet at the base level,
you don't even have the lifegiving,
soul-saving gospel message.
God says your guys's gospel is cursed.
The apostles didn't preach it.
Yet Paul says there's only one gospel,
and it's the one they preached, not a
limited gospel and the fullness of the
gospel restored.
You guys don't even properly understand
what Christians believe about the nature
of the soul. We looked at this last week
with Irenaeus explaining.
You guys think we believe everyone has
natural immortality.
No, that's not what Christians believe.
We believe God alone has natural
immortality and he sustains the souls of
individuals.
That doesn't open the door to
spiritualism and the occult. Sir,
number 14. derision regarding the
well-accepted seventh day adventist
understanding of the last day prophetic
events outlined in Daniel, Matthew,
Revelation, and the book the great
controversy. There are some who dismiss
the historicist's prophetic
understanding accepted by the 7th day
Adventist church. Don't be deceived into
thinking that there are explanations for
endtime events other than that shown
through Daniel, Matthew, and Revelation
and other books and by the great
controversy in Revelation 13. The beast
from the sea is the papacy and the beast
from the earth with two horns like a
lamb and speaks like a dragon is the
United States. A three-fold
confederation of apostate Protestantism,
Roman Catholicism, and spiritualism will
develop, producing a loss of religious
liberty as Sunday keeping will be
enforced, resulting in the receiving of
the mark of the beast by those who do
not stand for the Lord and his Bible
truth of keeping the seventh day Sabbath
holy. Read the biblical prophecies and
the book, The Great Controversy, and you
will be reaffirmed about the endtime
events. Be a strong advocate of
religious liberty and freedom of
conscience during these last days of
Earth's history. God will triumph and
bring his people through very difficult
times.
Notice he lumps in the great controversy
with Daniel, Revelation, Matthew, etc.
Adventist, is it clear at this point why
this platform states what we do around
Ellen White's writings? I understand you
might disagree, but that's not what this
platform's about. It's about the SDA
organization's official position, not
individual SDA opinions.
What TED is espousing is the
organization's official positions and
heritage.
He says historicism is basically a
foundational position. It's a deception
to think otherwise. He said
this is one of the few times they love
to appeal to the reformers to try and
say they were all historicists. So see
we're just in line with them.
Yeah. Yet they were all they were all
universal and other stuff that you guys
reject as well. So who cares? That means
nothing. They weren't infallible and
esquetology was not the central focus of
their day. which is why people like John
Calvin refrained from doing a commentary
on revelation.
It wasn't the central foundation of
their understanding of theology like the
SDA church is. Which is why one doesn't
have to be a historicist to be reformed
or Anglican.
Even though Calvin and others may have
been,
esquetology is not the foundation of the
Christian faith. This is again the great
controversy theme clouding your
judgments.
But also, what about prior to the
reformers, Ted?
Adventism has this idea that everyone
prior to the Reformation was just in the
dark and no theology was really
understood. And the Reformation was the
kickstart of that leading to a
restoration in the 19th century. Like it
started with the apostles, went
completely apostate. There was a
reformation leading to a restoration
like a boomerang swing.
total historical revisionism due to
ironically the great controversy, the
book where Ellen White does exactly
that. She rewrites history.
No, folks, church history didn't start
with the Reformation.
He paraphrases Ellen White claiming it's
Bible truth.
Again, Ted, you're confused. You
exhorted people to believe the plain
reading of the Bible, yet none of what
you said is plainly in the Bible.
Nothing about America, the papacy, a
national Sunday law, loss of religious
liberty. You're crossing wires again,
sir. That is your interpretation. Don't
confuse that with the plain reading of
the text.
You guys simply think you have an
infallible one. And she and since she
tells you what the text means, you think
it's plain Bible truth when no, it
isn't. And rejecting such does not mean
that somebody's rejecting scripture.
This is further evidence that you guys
do indeed equate Ellen White's writings
with scripture. Because if we reject
your bad interpretation, which is coming
from her, it's equated with rejecting
Bible truth. Not at all. Because we have
been chosen for mission.
Lack of enthusiasm for direct personal
and public evangelistic outreach. As
Seventh Day Adventists who are chosen
for mission, be active in sharing your
faith in every possible way, including
involvement in mission to the cities,
comprehensive health ministry, total
member involvement, and the church's I
will go strategic plans. I loved what
our doctor said last night. The church
doesn't have a program for I will stay,
only for I will go.
Personal and public evangelistic
outreach is the lifeblood of the
Adventist movement. Reject the leadyian
approach of doing nothing. God wants us
to be part of his far-reaching
evangelistic efforts. We are chosen for
mission.
Number 16. Neutralization of personal
Christian lifestyle and church
comportment through worldly influences.
remain faithful to God's injunctions to
live a pure and simple lifestyle as a
witness to the world of what God can do
in a consecrated life. The devil is busy
bringing into our lives and church
activities evil influences that affect
our lifestyles,
business activities, music,
recreation,
entertainment, what we wear, eating and
drinking habits in relation to God's
health reform and other lifestyle
activities. It is my observation I will
tell you again
that God is beginning the shaking and
sifting of his precious Advent movement.
By God's grace, let us live pure and
simple lives in accordance with biblical
revival and reformation reflecting our
close relationship with and dependence
on Jesus Christ our Lord. Let's take
time for daily reading of the Bible,
study of the spirit of prophecy, and
engaging in earnest prayer, imploring
the Lord for the latter reign of the
Holy Spirit. Then let us share with
others the wonderful power and salvation
of God. We are chosen for mission.
So this is again more Adventisms being
conflated with the Bible.
Now we're getting into the avenous
temperance and and lifestyle doctrines.
By simple lifestyle, TED means those
things which are basically a lab
designed projection of what Ellen White
claimed Jesus was like. And if you
aren't a carbon copy of that projection,
then you aren't Christlike. I get
Adventists all the time that love to say
stuff like, "I can tell by your spirit
that you aren't very that you aren't
very Christlike." Using Ellen White's
caricature of who Jesus was as the
baseline.
In Adventism, there's no concept of
people having different personalities.
Some people more fiery than others, like
the sons of thunder, some more
passionate, etc.
This was always interesting to me when I
was an Adventist. You always heard about
this sort of passive, weak, beggar
picture of Jesus who was just a pushover
and a doormat basically, and that's how
everyone was expected to act and be. And
if you weren't, you supposedly weren't
Christlike. Yet, very few people I knew
fell into that category.
even the people touting this. And as Ted
said, it's supposed to be what attracts
people to Adventism by showing people
this character that Ellen White put
forth of who Jesus is.
Yet that caricature never includes
anything about Jesus's righteous anger.
The fact that God hates evil, he wasn't
always a pushover. That there's a time
and a season for certain things.
It just h
now these and and other confusing
interruptions by the devil
tend to destroy our calling as chosen
for mission.
Resist those temptations by false
teachers to deviate from our biblical
beliefs and heaven sentent mission.
Otherwise, we will become like second
Peter chapter 2:1 17, which says, "These
are wells without water, clouds carried
by a tempest, for whom is reserved the
blackness of darkness forever."
The book of Jude echoes this in verses
12 to 19. They are clouds without water,
late autumn leaves without fruit, raging
waves of the sea, foaming up their own
shame, wandering stars for who has
reserved the blackness of darkness
forever. Grumblers, complainers, walking
according to their own lusts, flattering
people to gain advantage,
mockers in the last time, sensual people
who cause divisions not having the
spirit.
This is the world, my dear fellow
leaders and church members, in which we
now live with the devil distracting us
from God's mission. But the devil will
not succeed because we were chosen for
mission. In 2 Thessalonians 2:13 and 14,
it tells us, "We are bound to give
thanks to God always for you, brethren,
beloved by the Lord, because God from
the beginning chose you for salvation
through sanctification by the Spirit and
belief in the truth to which he called
you by our gospel for the obtaining of
the glory of Lord Jesus Christ."
Regardless of the confusing
interruptions
to God's mission, God is completely in
control of the destiny of the Seventh
Day Adventist Church.
He is in control of the proclamation of
the Advent movement.
In control of the Advent message, God
chose us to be part of his final cry to
the world. Ephesians chapter 1 vers 3
and 4. Blessed be the God and father of
our Lord Jesus Christ who has blessed us
with every spiritual blessing in the
heavenly places in Christ just as he
chose us in him before the foundation of
the world. He chose us, my brothers and
sisters, that we should be holy and
without blame before him in love.
Ted, I couldn't agree more. God is in
con complete control
even of the SDA church
which is why the organization not the
people
will be made his foottool eventually
as all of his enemies will
movement is preaching a false gospel
that's cursed by God.
The devil doesn't need to infiltrate the
movement Ted.
He already has it. It's part of the
great apostasy.
It's one of the many movements in the
world that's against the true Christ and
his kingdom.
And the fact that you quote Ephesians 1
at the tail end there,
not only did you ignore the fact that it
goes on to specifically and and again by
your own standard state that the Holy
Spirit's the seal,
you ignore the union with Christ
language of in him and don't realize
that when a person is born again, united
to Christ by faith, they receive all of
the benefits that come with that.
One of which is being holy and blameless
before God by virtue of being in Christ
who is the only one who is truly holy
and blameless. Which is why a person can
be ready today for Christ's return or if
they're to die
because Christ is enough.
You can be hidden in him.
It's not something you attain toward and
eventually arrive at.
You're already disqualified by having
sinned even one time.
There are no doovers. The gospel is not
that Christ came to give you a doover to
now try and get to a sinless state by
obeying the law
such that you're at that point holy and
blameless. That is not at all what is in
focus. Ted,
I I mean part of the part of the the
being predestined and chosen from the
foundation of the world includes the
being holy and blameless.
Jesus is holy and blameless. He alone is
and by being in him, the believer is as
well.
Along with all the other benefits you
receive by being united to him. Go to
our website, folks. Type in the search
bar union with Christ.
Union with Christ is the heart of the
gospel. And sadly, the Adventist church
does not understand it.
Which is why we will keep laboring this
gospel field with our plow firmly
planted in. We're not going anywhere,
Ted.
You can call us weird people online or
whatever else. Not going to work
anymore.
It may have worked in the past with
people like Canrite and Dale Ratzlaf and
Des Ford, but those days are over.
We're going to keep reaching Adventists.
We're going to keep impacting your
retention numbers because like you said,
God is in complete control and he has a
people
and some of those people are caught in
the clutches of Adventism.
So by God's grace that will change and
they will come to know the actual good
news. Find true freedom in Christ.
Truly be prepared for the second coming
by being united to Christ, having peace
with God. Romans 5:1. and learn that
obedience is the fruit of already having
that
good works are the result of being born
again, not something that supplement
your faith on a pathway to eventually
making it if you try hard enough.
God did not choose a band of uneducated,
anti-trinitarian, anti-gosspel heretics
to restore the church in the 19th
century, to raise up an end times group
or anything of the sort. That alone is
the dead giveaway that this movement was
not started by God. They are accusers of
the brethren, the actual body of Christ.
Everything you accuse others of, you
guys exude.
The SDA church is not the commandment
church.
Because commandment keeping doesn't
entail going to church on Saturday. It
entails obeying the gospel of the Lord
Jesus Christ and the law of Christ,
which entails far more than just the
letter of the Ten Commandments.
But even on that standard, you guys
aren't 10 commandmentkeeping. You have
an idol. You make images of persons of
the Godhead. You elevate a woman who
bore the name of God falsely,
repeatedly, and claim we have to listen
to her if we want to know the truth
about the Bible and salvation. You guys
don't keep the Sabbath. You're not
resting in Christ. Not even the old
creation Sabbath. You guys have a false
cursed gospel and haven't entered into
the true rest of Christ just like Israel
failed to do. You guys are the
wilderness wanderers in the wilderness
of life, just not in in the contained
physical loca locality.
You're who the author of Hebrews is is
crying out to and warning.
Yet you think because you go to church
on Saturday, you're good to go.
You guys lie about Christians and bear
false witness about us, which is
hardcoded into your systems theology,
breaking the ninth commandment. Your
hospitals murder the unborn, and you
guys make money off of it, breaking the
sixth commandment.
With that said, if you like what we're
doing here, you want to partner with us,
donate, access more resources, sign up
for our newsletter, all that good stuff,
make sure folks, visit
answeringadaptism.com.
That site is our gift to you. Use it.
It's a powerful tool. Christian, you
have to equip yourself to reach
Adventists with the truth. This is an
unreached, overlooked people group. Most
of them are well-meaning, nice,
upstanding people.
They've simply been duped and confused
and taken captive by this deceptive
movement, which is a tool of Satan, and
it's pumped their mind full of all this
theological fog to confuse them.
So study this stuff. Get equipped
so that you can be used by God to be the
light that breaks through that fog.
Because the good thing about fog is that
it's temporary. It's temporary.
Thank you for being here. This was a
long night. I didn't anticipate this
going as long as it did, but it was
necessary. We needed to respond to this.
There was some good stuff here. Like I
said, we're not slowing down here. So if
you're an Adventist leader, buckle up.
We're making a difference. We've got the
receipts to prove it. We've got the
analytics and the data to prove it.
We're only growing. Our website is
booming off the charts.
We're here. The old games, you can say
what you want. You don't know what
you're talking about. You're confused.
That's out of context. Well, whatever.
It's not going to stop us. It's not
going to slow it's not going to slow
things down. It's not going to stop
people from coming to know the truth.
Christ is king. Christ is ruling and
reigning. His kingdom is advancing. His
gospel is undefeated. It's not my
gospel. It's not answering Adventism's
gospel. This is Christ's gospel. And
people have tried. Communism's tried.
Secularism's tried. Roman government
tried.
All sorts of Islam's tried.
It's not going to work. It's undefeated.
Christ is ruling and reigning. His
gospel knows no ends. Avenous, we want
you to come to know that. So the call
that you've had for us is come out of
her, my people. Our call is back to you.
come out of her, Ellen White, if you're
one of his sheep. That's what we want
for you. Why don't you come to know the
truth? We don't hate you. We're intense
here because again, this is spiritual
warfare, folks. This is not kid glove.
We're on the front lines. Not everybody
needs to be that way. That's fine.
Until next time, as always, God bless.
[Music]